George Jugu, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Avec plaisir. Bonsoir et merci de
m'avoir invité. Mon nom est George Uux.
Je suis né en Belgique où j'ai passé
toute mon enfance et toute ma formation
universitaire qui s'est faite à
l'université catholique de Louvin où
j'ai connu une période troublée puisque
nous avons dû euh gérer le nationalisme
flamant qui a voulu qu'une université
francophone ne soit pas en terre
flamante ce qui a créé après ça Nouvel
après cette formation de droit et
d'économie je j'ai commencé en banque à
la générale de banque et j'ai fait une
quinzaine de d'années de banquier de
type commercial. J'ai fait pourtant dans
cette activité, l'activité de gestion de
portefeuille, mais aussi j'ai appris ce
que c'était que la banque quand on est
dans une agence au milieu d'un village
et où on vient vous apporter le fruit
des récoltes.
Euh après ça, je suis euh entré après
les années de banque, je suis parti à
Londres une première fois pour Morgan
Stanley où j'ai euh développé l'activity
fusion acquisition. à l'époque, c'était
nouveau pour Morgan Salian en Europe. Et
puis j'ai eu un appel du pays,
c'est-à-dire que Hervid Carmois, avec
qui j'étais dans un avion euh m'a
expliqué qu'il allait devenir le patron
de la générale de Belgique avec Stevie
d'Avignon et il m'a demandé si je
voulais pas devenir directeur financier
parce qu'il y avait pas de directeur
financier à la générale de Belgique à
França, ce que j'ai fait pendant
quelques années. Et puis je suis reparti
sur l'ombre cette fois-ci pour Kiderpy
Body. là qui body était une filiale de
général électrique et je me suis
retrouvé
avec
Jack Welge Paulo Fresco a géré la
filiale anglaise en matière de banque
d'affaires. Et puis il est arrivé une
petite catastrophe, c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a quelqu'un qui a manipulé les comptes
aux États-Unis euh et on a dû sauver
Général électrique a dû sauver
l'entreprise et la dépessé. Je suis
retourné en Europe continentale à
Luxembourg où je suis devenu le patron
d'un nouveau fond qui s'appelle le fond
européen d'investissement qui fait des
financements de structure mais qui fait
aussi beaucoup de private equity et qui
fait aussi beaucoup de financement de
PME à travers la Commission européenne.
C'est détenu à travers l'Europe. C'est
détenu par la Commission européenne,
c'est détenu par la Banque européenne
d'investissement que je représentais et
par 75 banques de l'Union européenne.
Là-dessus, j'ai eu un ancien collègue de
Kiderpody qui m'a appelé en disant
"Est-ce que ça t'intéresserait de
devenir le patron de l'international à
la bourse de New York ?" Et quand je
suis rentré à la maison pour expliquer
ça, ma femme m'a dit "Je veux bien mais
on ne quittera New York que si je le
décide." Et donc nous avons fait un deal
ensemble. Je suis parti à New York et
j'ai vécu plusieurs années responsable
de l'activité internationale, de la
recherche à travers le monde. Ça m'a
donné la stature internationale de ma
connaissance de la finance et des
marchés financiers.
Et puis quand à un moment donné la
réglementation américaine a rendu ces
opérations moins intéressantes pour les
sociétés étrangères, j'ai réalisé mon
rêve, c'est-à-dire que j'ai créé ma
propre firme Galileo Global Advisors,
qui est totalement une firme de conseil
en fusion acquisition et cetera et qui
travaille essentiellement à travers les
frontières.
Et puis j'y suis toujours et puis
progressivement j'ai développé des
activités un peu plus universitaires
puisque j'enseigne à la faculté de
droits de Colombia School, International
Banking and Finance et en même temps un
nouveau cours sur les banques centrales.
Donc on peut vous dire que vous êtes un
banquier de classe internationale.
On a décidé de vous faire venir pour
avoir quelques éclairages,
éclaircissements et et lumière
concernant la finance Wall Street,
l'évasion fiscale, l'optimisation
fiscale et tout tout ce vocable, tout ce
vocabulaire, toute cette dialectique
complexifiée à dessin.
Est-ce que la finance nous en fume et
est-ce que la finance est néfaste pour
nos démocraties ?
Je crois que ce que nous venons de vivre
avec la pandémie,
c'est quand même un paradoxe complet.
Le chômage, l'intervention des
gouvernements et la bourse qui monte de
150 %.
Il est donc très clair aujourd'hui et
nous connaissons ce phénomène depuis la
crise précédente parce que la bourse a
monté quatre fois depuis la crise
précédente. Il y a donc un phénomène qui
fait que là ceux qui ont accès à la
finance, ceux qui sont actionnaires sont
ceux qui ont véritablement fait de
l'argent. pas de croissance véritable en
général pour la population et avec et on
y viendra un certain nombre d'inégalités
structurelles qui vont nécessairement
favoriser à la fois les gouvernements et
les grandes entreprises qui sont quelque
part ce que nous appelions en 1968 lors
de nos manifestations les alliés
objectifs.
Comment vous avez des petits enfants ?
Oui.
Comment vous voyez l'avenir pour la
jeune génération ? Est-ce que c'est un
avenir où on va continuer à faire
perdurer le rondrond quotidien ? Est-ce
que vous vous attendez à une émergence
de menaces, de risque pour la jeune
génération ?
J'ai un énorme respect pour la jeune
génération. Mes petits-enfants, j'ai une
petite fille qui est d'ailleurs en
Bretagne et qui a 16 ans maintenant.
les autres sont plus jeunes. Quand je
pense à eux, j'écoute et ce que
j'écoute, c'est un message extrêmement
clair qui nous dit que nous nous
trompons de direction. Je crois qu'il
n'y a aucun doute que en règle générale
la génération des jeunes trouve que nous
ne nous occupons pas des vrais
problèmes. Que ce soit les retraites,
que ce soit la santé et nous venons de
le démontrer et certainement par rapport
au climat. Par contre, je suis fier
d'eux parce qu'ils nous interpellent et
je suis particulièrement fier que ce
soit en Europe.
Quelle menace vous avez identifié ?
Est-ce que la finance internationale
représente une menace ? Et quel type de
menace ? Est-ce que c'est une menace par
corruption ? Est-ce que c'est une menace
par sécession financière ? Est-ce que
c'est une menace
plus diffuse ?
Comme j'ai utilisé le terme de
l'alliance objective, je vais aller un
petit peu plus loin en vous disant qu'il
y a entre les grandes entreprises, les
gouvernements et les banques centrales
une forme de collusion.
Et il y a aussi un phénomène qui s'est
produit en 1970.
Milton Freedman a sorti son fameux
article sur tout pour les actionnaires
et la Cherold Value comme on dit en
anglais est a immédiatement appris aux
États-Unis et ce capitalisme anglo-saxon
est arrivé dans les années 70 et 80 à
partir de Londres sur le continent
européen et toute une série
d'entreprises ont pu se développer dans
ce modèle là. Le problème c'est que si
vous voyez ce que ce modèle là a donné
en terme d'inégalité aux États-Unis, il
faut bien se rendre compte que l'Europe
n'est pas d'accord avec ce modèle. Elle
le subit, elle en mais il y a beaucoup
de gens qui en profitent. Et donc on est
dans cette ambiguïté entre la catégorie
de ceux qui peuvent en profiter et la
catégorie de ceux qui ne peuvent
absolument pas en profiter et c'est là
que l'inégalité joue.
Comment combler ces inégalités ? Est-ce
qu'il faut mettre la finance au pas ?
Quand on essaie de mettre la finance au
pas, quand on essaie de séparer les
banques d'affaires des banques de
détail, quand on essaie de faire passer
un Glassle Act, quand on essaie de de
tordre le coût aux paradis fiscaux, euh
la haute finance trouve toujours le
moyen de nous échapper. Est-ce que vous
avez des hypothèses et des solutions
pour pouvoir les attraper ? Est-ce qu'il
faut rendre l'optimisation fiscale
illégale ? Est-ce qu'il faut un groupe
d'État qui tape du point sur la table en
disant on va on va faire vraiment de
l'harmonisation fiscale ou est-ce que
c'est peine perdu ? Non, ce n'est pas
peine perdu et je dirais il y a 6 mois,
je ne vous aurais pas dit la même chose
parce que l'administration Biden à
travers le G, c'était le G20, a mis en
chantier une réforme qui va créer un
minimum d'impôts à travers le système et
d'un autre côté qui va régler le
problème de la technologie qui ne paye
pas d'impôts et surtout qui utilise les
territoires nationaux au niveau
cybernétique mais qui ne leur demande
pas de payer pour les revenus.
Donc il y a de l'espoir seulement il
faut aller plus loin que je dirais cette
inégalité
globale. Parce que ce qui est très
intéressant dans le monde de des marchés
financiers c'est que vous avez toute une
série de petits éléments qui comme par
hasard mis ensemble vont tous dans le
même sens.
Et il est évident par exemple que
aujourd'hui
nous avons une difficulté fondamentale
avec les gouvernements. Les
gouvernements s'en dettent. Ils
financent la croissance de plus en plus
avec la dette. Et comme on ne trouve
plus nécessairement preneur pour la
dette et qu'on veut que les taux
d'intérêt soient bas, on fait en sorte
que ce soit les banques centrales qui le
souscrivent. Alors, je vais vous dans le
livre que j'ai publié qui s'appelle donc
Wall Street à l'assaut de la démocratie,
comment les marchés financiers exacerb
les inégalités que j'ai publié chez
Audit Jacob. Dans ce livre là, j'ai fait
une analyse dans laquelle j'ai découvert
deux trois choses. La première chose,
c'est que le citoyen ne sait pas
grand-chose de ce qui se passe. Et donc
ce que j'ai essayé de faire émerger dans
ce livre, entre autres, c'est un
phénomène auquel dont on parle très peu.
Sur les 10 dernières années,
75 %
de baisse du taux d'impôt des sociétés.
Aujourd'hui
dans l'OCDE, c'est quand même beaucoup
de monde, c'est notre Occident.
Moins de 10 % est apporté par les
sociétés,
50 % par la consommation, c'est-à-dire
la TVA, qui n'est certainement pas
égalitaire, qui est égalitaire mais qui
n'est certainement pas favorable
aux pauvres et bien entendu toute la
masse salariale.
Donc depuis 10 ans ou depuis 20 ans, les
entreprises ont réussi à convaincre les
gouvernements qu'il fallait surtout
qu'on ne les taxe pas parce que vous
comprenez, il y a une concurrence
fiscale.
C'est là qu'on commence à devoir
regarder les choses de près. Pourquoi ?
Parce que la courbe qui est mise là, qui
vient du fond monétaire international,
c'est que tout le monde l'a fait.
Donc c'est pas parce que quelqu'un
subitement était moins pris mal pris par
rapport à l'autre. Tout le monde a
baissé ces empreints et donc tout le
monde se retrouve avec un endettement et
la pandémie fait éclater le problème.
Pourquoi ? Parce que subitement les
gouvernements mettent et on y reviendra
17000 milliards de dollars d'action et
les banques centrales souscrivent dans
cette dette là à 9000 milliards. Et donc
on a des banques centrales qui sont
pleines d'emprunt d'État. Nous avons un
endettement extraordinaire. Pourquoi ?
parce que nous dépensons trop dans la
défense, pas tellement l'Europe mais les
États-Unis et parce qu'en terme de
revenus, on a réussi à faire en sorte
que pratiquement les grandes entreprises
rassent gratuites.
On parlait de l'administration Biden et
de cette harmonisation fiscale. Ils vont
faire quoi avec leower ? Ils vont
l'envahir ? Ils vont ils vont faire quoi
? Le paradis fiscal. Une obsession sur
le
soyons extrêmement clair. On paye
l'impôt fédéral. dans tous les
États-Unis
à l'extérieur.
Non, mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
vous soyez une entreprise établie au
Delaware, en Floride ou dans l'état de
New York, vous payez l'impôt fédéral qui
est à 35 % pour enfin qu'on a remonté à
32 %. Celui-là c'est le même pour tout
le monde. Il y a des différences entre
les États mais c'est sur la part
supplémentaire au-delà. Donc ce a pas
tellement contrairement à ce que l'on
croit
de de paradis fiscaux. Mais il y a une
chose qui est très intéressante,
c'est qu'il est évident que sur le plan
éthique et nous venons de voir les
Pandora Papers après avoir eu les
Panorama Papers,
on va en reparler d'ailleurs,
je suis sûr qu'on va en parler mais je
veux dire il y a des particuliers
qui font de la fraude fiscale. Alors
appelons un chat un chat c'est une
opération de fraude c'est pénal et c'est
en principe en prison que ça se dissou
en tout cas avec les amendes.
Ça c'est le particulier.
Mais c'est pas là qui est la fraude
fiscale.
La vraie fraude fiscale, ce sont les
arrangements fiscaux et à travers des
grandes entreprises qui parviennent à
situer leurs revenus dans des endroits
qui ne payent pas d'impôts. Je vous
donner un exemple aux États-Unis, la
[grognement] faute fiscale est à peu
près estimée à 1300 milliards de
dollars. Je vous signale que le budget
de l'État, c'est 4500 milliards de
dollars. Donc c'est un montant
significatif
des entreprises.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'aux États-Unis, vous
n'êtes taxé que si vous rapatriez.
Donc si vous ne rapatriez pas vos
bénéfices et que vous les mettez dans
les îles FIDji,
pas de taxation. Et donc il y a un
phénomène dans lequel les entreprises
ont réussi à euh contrôler l'appareil
législatif et l'appareil gouvernemental
en leur faveur. Et tout ça fait
évidemment d'excellents dividendes et
beaucoup de return pour les
actionnaires.
Avant avant vous au Nice, il y a eu
Bernard Madof.
Qui c'était Bernard Madof ?
Alors, Bernie Madov, c'est un homme que
j'ai rencontré.
Pourquoi ? Parce que quand j'étais à la
bourse de New York, il était le chairman
du NASDAQ, le grand concurrent.
Alors, pour vous situer l'ordre de
grandeur, le NASDAQ est allé installer
un marché sur le Moyen-Orient, mais il a
décidé de l'établir à tel avis.
Normal,
c'est évidemment le centre du
Moyen-Orient comme chacun sait.
Mais je reviens là ce que B Mad.
Qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ?
Il a simplement
payé
à ceux qui avaient mis de l'argent avec
l'argent de ceux qui mettaient le nouvel
argent. À un moment donné, la musique
s'arrête.
Pyramide de Ponzi.
La pyramide de Ponzi. Absolument.
Mais c'est beaucoup plus grave que ça.
Les comptes étaient faux et il n'y avait
pas de possibilité de contrôler où se
trouvaient les titres dont on a
découvert qu'il n'existait pas.
et pour 50 milliards.
Donc fondamentalement c'est un fraudeur.
Mais d'ailleurs il va mourir, il est
mort je crois maintenant en prison. Il
va mourir en prison.
Est-ce que la finance, les gens
travaillant dans la haute finan
est-ce que ils ont pas un petit
phénomène de mégalomanie,
un petit peu de toxicomanie lié au
pouvoir ? Est-ce que les régulateurs
peuvent vraiment les mettre ou pas ?
Il y a deux catégories
importantes dans ce monde là. Il y a
ceux qui cherchent le pouvoir, il y a
ceux qui cherchent l'argent et il y a
ceux qui cherchent les deux. Mais ce ne
sont pas les mêmes objectif. Un trader,
la seule chose qui l'intéresse, c'est
aujourd'hui j'ai fait 100000 dollars
parce qu'il sait calculer exactement
comment sa commission va lui revenir.
Donc lui, il vit au jour le jour, il
veut être sûr, il gagne de l'argent et
puis après ça, plus il en gagne, mieux
c'est. Il ne se préoccupe de rien
d'autre et il vit vraiment sur le très
court terme. Il y a de plus en plus
d'opérateurs de marché qui sont sur le
court terme. Par contre, il y a des gens
qui construisent les empires. Ça existe
partout. Vous en avez en France et il y
en a aux États-Unis.
Vous avez des noms ?
Euh je pense que Vivindi est un empire.
Je pense que Boloré est un empire.
Je pense que ce sont des structures de
pouvoir autant que des structures
d'argent. C'est
grave de dire ça.
Non, s'il n'abuseent pas de leur
pouvoir, il y a pas de problème. Avoir
le pouvoir de l'argent et l'utiliser
peut se faire de manière
extraordinairement positive ou
extraordinairement négative. Mais si
vous commencez à en abuser, le point que
vous faites évoquer et qui est
extrêmement intéressant, c'est pas la
régulation qui est en cause parce que
les règles sont là. Par définition, si
vous abusez, c'est que vous transgressez
les règles de manière plus ou moins
visible. Et on a connu des cas dans
lesquels on a découvert le poteau rose,
mais il y a pas eu de sanction. Pourquoi
? parce que les régulateurs sont nommés
par les gouvernements et que les amis
des gouvernements ne vont pas
nécessairement être sanctionnés de la
même manière que vous et moi.
La régulation est là, elle doit être
robuste et elle doit être indépendante.
C'est pas le cas. La régulation, on peut
toujours s'arranger. Vous m'avez dit
c'est illégal. Quelle est la différence
entre illégal et allégal ? Si si si je
veux
àégal, c'est une situation dans laquelle
le panorama légal est insuffisant.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas assez de lois
et de règles qui s'impose à vous. Alors
là, c'est une faute de législation,
c'est une faute de réglementation et ça
peut être à ce moment-là corrigé en
changeant la réglementation
illégal. La règle existe mais vous la
transgressez siamment.
Et ça [grognement] c'est à ce moment-là
quand on est dans l'illégalité, on est
au pénal, on n plus du tout au civil où
vous résolz votre problème avec des
amendes. Et donc c'est pour ça que dans
des cas comme ceuxlà, on va mettre les
gens en prison.
Il y a pas eu beaucoup de personnes en
prison avec la crise de 2008
parce que c'était pas illégal.
La réglementation n'était pas là pour s
pour créer les parfeux. on l'a créé
après pour que les parfeux existent
aujourd'hui. Mais au moment où les les
grandes informations, les grandes
opérations qui ont été faites par les
banques et prenons l'emmen Brothers, ils
ont évidemment
euh pris des risques considérables
qu'ils ont extrêmement mal gérés. Ils en
ont utilisé à des fins que vous pouvez
imaginer. Tout ça c'est extrêmement bien
mais ça se situait dans la légalité
et le contrôle qui était exercé par laC
était totalement faible. SC en français,
la SC l'équivalent de votre autorité des
marchés. Donc c'est l'autorité qui elle
vise les marchés. L'autorité qui vise
les banques, c'est en général les
banques centrales.
Mais
est-ce que les banques centrales sont
indépendantes ? Elles sont pas
indépendantes.
Les banques centrales ne peuvent pas
être indépendantes puisque par
définition, la nomination des banques
centrales euh est faite par le
gouvernement. Toutefois,
jusqu'il a un certain temps,
les banques centrales ont joui d'une
autonomie en matière de politique
monétaire,
même si régulièrement vos présidents en
France ont trouvé que l'indépendance de
la BCE était quelque chose de scandaleux
et qu'il s'agissait d'obéir au
gouvernement. Bien,
mais ce qui est occupé à se passer, ça
n'est absolument pas que le l'activité
monétaire des banques, la politique
monétaire a profondément changé. Non.
Ils ont commencé à s'occuper de la
politique budgétaire.
Quand vous commencez à devenir le
porteur d'eau de l'État et que vous
devenez le plus grand obligataire en
emprunt d'État,
vous êtes complètement pied point lié
par rapport à qui ? le ministre des
finances, le gouvernement et ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est exactement ça.
Le les banques central ont actuellement
un paquet qui représente, je m'excuse
mais il faut voir les chiffres,
l'ensemble des actifs des banques
centrales, c'est quand même 50000
milliards de dollars. D'accord ? Et
le PIB mondial, c'est
80 Le PIB mondial c'est
21000 milliards. Non
non non non non. Le 21000 milliards,
c'est celui des États-Unis tout seul.
Mais enfin, le PIB mondial n'est pas
loin de ça. Au Japon, la banque centrale
détient une fois le PIB. Aux États-Unis,
c'est 25 %. En Europe, c'est 40. Donc,
chacun a son petit système. Mais la
réalité des choses, c'est que il y a une
chose inquiétante, c'est qu'à partir du
moment vous vous rendez bien compte que
vous écoutez le ministre des finances,
d'accord ?
Lequel ? Lequel ?
Le prenez le maire.
Je vous dis deux choses.
L'économie est ouverte,
il y a pas de problème. Attention hein,
il est pas faux. C'est un type
intelligent.
C'est vrai que l'économie est ouverte,
elle va mieux mais il parle pas de la
finance. Or, il est ministre des
finances et dans la dette, lui, il en a
pris un paquet. Alors, vous avez ce
problème là face auquel
vous avez cet élément là. Et le deuxième
élément, c'est qu'il vous dit aussi
quelque chose et il y a un certain
nombre de gens qui s'amusent à dire ça
et je vous avoue que je suis un peu
inquié sur leur honnêteté intellectuelle
et qui disent la dette publique c'est
pas un problème, on doit jamais la
rembourser et de toute façon on ne paye
pas d'intérêt puisque les intérêts sont
à zéro
ou négatif
ou voire négatif. Exactement. Donc dans
une structure comme celle-là, il y a pas
de danger. Sauf que vous devez imaginer
que à terme, on ne va jamais avoir une
hausse des taux d'intérêt. Et qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé aux États-Unis ? On est
descendu jusqu'à 0,25 % pour le 10 ans,
il est à 1,75.
Les taux montent. La charge de la dette
publique va devenir importante parce que
c'est pas le montant que vous devez
rembourser qui est un problème. C'est
l'intérêt que vous allez devoir payer
là-dessus. Plus le montant est important
et s'il est au monde, vous avez un
double effet. On parle de certaines
projections dans lesquelles on pourrait
arriver aux États-Unis jusqu'à 40 % du
budget de l'État qui sert exclusivement
à payer les intérêts parce que les
remboursements c'est pas dans le budget.
Ça va nous emmener où ? Parce que ma
grand-mère
ça peut nous mener qu'à une catastrophe
si on corrige pas.
Ma grand-mère digit toujours
un jour ou l'autre tout se pa.
Oui.
Raison votre grand-mère.
Elle a eu beaucoup raison.
Euh, on va on va avoir quoi ? Si si la
vitesse monétaire s'accélère,
on va avoir de l'inflation.
Les gens vont avoir sur les les matières
premières alimentaires une augmentation.
C'est une bombe à retardement. Oui ou
non ?
Dans le livre précédent que j'avais
écrit aussi chez Oli Jacob qui était sur
le la finance au bord du précipice,
je parlais déjà de ce sujet-là et les
gens m'ont dit "Tu as vu, tu t'es
trompé." Et la réponse que je dis c'est
que non, ça s'est produit en mars 2000
20. Pourquoi ? Parce que la pandémie,
elle s'est mise sur un terrain qui était
déjà complètement miné. Mais à partir du
moment où vous utilisez le bazooka dans
tous les domaines et que vous mettez
16000 milliards ou 9000 milliards dans
le système, c'est évident qu'il va pas
se casser la figure. Alors la question
c'est il va plus y avoir de crise
pendant 20 ans. Bien sûr, on ne va plus
jamais avoir de problèmes et on ne va
jamais avoir de problèmes de
financement. Et c'est là qu'il y a un
mythe. Mais personne ne regarde au-delà
de l'année ou des 2 ans. Et un un des
problèmes fondamentals, c'est que là le
citoyen est important. C'est pour ça que
je reviens sur la démocratie.
La taxation
des entre la non taxation des des
grandes entreprises,
le mouvement qui est en train de se
mettre, il faudrait qu'il soit soutenu
par l'opinion public de manière
extraordinaire. Qu'est-ce que vous lisez
dans les médias ? Oui, mais ça va pas se
faire et puis c'est trop compliqué et
puis il y a c et puis il y a ça. Non, il
faut C'est insuffisant 15 % d'accord
mais c'est mieux que zéro.
Faudrait combien
le minimum ? Il faut au moins atteindre
25 %. J'ai pas de problème à ce qu'on le
fasse en 5 ans. Je crois qu'il faut
donner le temps au temps. Il faut
arrêter le l'utilisation des deniers
publics par les banques centrales pour
continuer à maintenir les taux d'intérêt
relativement bas. Et il faut monter les
taux d'intérêt parce que aujourd'hui, je
peux vous dire que si le taux d'intérêt
passe de 0 % à 0,5 %, il ne se passera
rien.
On vous prétend l'inverse, c'est la fin
du monde. La la la reprise ne pourra pas
fonctionner. Je suis désolé, le chef
d'entreprise qui ne fait pas un
investissement parce que son coûte passe
de 2 à 2,5 % mérite d'être viré. il est
sur des investissements à 10 ans. Pour
lui, c'est pas un demi% qui va changer
sa décision d'investir. Il a beaucoup
plus de d'éléments de décision qui sont
importants. Donc la croissance, elle va
pas se financer. Elle a réussi à se
financer à 5 6 %. C'est pas pour ça
qu'elle a besoin de se trouver à zéro
aujourd'hui. Et le grand échec des
banques centrales, c'est précisément
toute la théorie euh économique qui dit
"Vous diminuez euh les taux d'intérêt et
à ce moment-là les investissements
reprendent et et l'économie reprend."
Oui, si vous passez de 7 à 3 %, mais si
vous passez de 0 à 0,5 % il ne se passe
rien.
C'est de la poudre aux yeux.
C'est pire que ça. C'est de l'idéologie.
C'est Modiglianie, c'est l'école de
Chicago. C'est toute une école
monétariste qui croit que le monétaire
peut gérer l'économique, il peut
l'influencer. Mais la décision
d'investir aujourd'hui est importante et
il y a quelque chose qui me gêne
profondément
et la statistique se trouve aussi dans
le livre.
Les entreprises ont trouvé un nouveau
nouvel mode. Je rachète mes propres
actions.
D'accord ? Alors première chose,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Ça veut
dire que vous rachetez vos actions, donc
vous diminuez votre capital
puisque les actions sont annulées.
Et ça vient d'où ? Soit vous avez du
cash et vous n'avez moins de cash, soit
vous allez faire de la dette. Et ça a
beaucoup été de la dette.
Pourquoi le faites-vous ? Parce que la
dette ne coûte plus rien.
Parce que la dette ne coûte plus rien.
Banque centrale et
parce que vous allez faire plaisir à vos
actionnaires. Ne demandez pas au conseil
d'administration de poser des questions.
Et on a réussi à boucler la boucle de la
manière suivante. Vous connaissez les
stock option, ce sont des options pour
rejeter des actions à un prix qui est
fixé. D'accord.
Ça c'est pas les BSA. Non, les bon
souscription d'action, c'est sur des
obligations, mais c'est ça revient au
même. Et donc, vous êtes sur des
options, c'est lié au cours de bourse.
Donc si vos bénéfices n'augmentent pas
et que votre cours de bourse augmente
quatre fois, c'est parfait. Bingo. Et
qu'est-ce qui paye ça ? l'entreprise
et donc vous vous trouvez devant un
système dans lequel le chef d'entreprise
a le même intérêt que le que
l'actionnaire et donc il va beaucoup
plus gérer son entreprise y compris
l'endettement en fonction d'une gestion
de son cours de bourse qu'en fonction de
la gestion à long terme de ses
investissements. il est en train de
traire son entreprise
évidemment. Et donc vous avez, je vous
donne un exemple, c'est Delta. Je vois
encore le patron de Delta 2 ans avant la
pandémie faire un extraordinaire
discours dans lequel il explique "Nous
avons réussi à restructurer notre
capital. Mes chers actionnaires, vous
devez être très heureux. Le cours est
passé de X à Y." Exactement. OK.
Arrive la pandémie.
Qui est-ce qui va venir au secours de
Delta ?
Nous
donc nous l'état
donc ils ont engraissé leurs
actionnaires et c'est nous qui devons
aller les sauver. Les actionnaires qui
font probablement de l'évasion fiscale,
ils ont même pas besoin de ça. Vous
savez quand vous faites 400 % pas besoin
d'aller loin.
Comment
on va dans le mur ?
Bien sûr
les peuples, les peuples vont jamais
pouvoir tolérer la charge de la dette.
Et c'est là le grand mystère pour moi.
Je ne demande pas aux entreprises,
au gouvernement et aux banques centrales
d'être vertueux.
Je crois qu'on demande la vertu aux gens
depuis suffisamment de siècles pour
savoir que ça ne sert à rien.
Je leur demande de regarder quel est
leur intérêt à long terme. Est-ce que
leur intérêt est de pousser tout le
système dans le précipice
ou quel cas bien sûr les plus riches
s'en tireront et les autres seront dans
le drame ?
Est-ce que c'est vraiment vers ça qu'on
va ? Vous savez quand on a baissé les
taux d'intérêt que les retraites et les
compagnies d'assurance vie et cetera ont
commencé à souffrir parce que les taux
étaient extrêmement bas, on a fait de
l'expropriation,
on a exproprié l'épargne en faveur de
l'émetteur, c'est-à-dire des
emprunteurs.
Et donc, on a favorisé à ce moment-là la
dette parce que la dette mondiale, je
vous ai parlé de 50 à 60 pour la dette
États souverain. La dette mondiale est
est de 2600 milliards de dollars. Il est
là triplé
en 10 ans.
Regardez la Chine quand même
intéressant. Je pré vous avez suivi
everground
est extraordinaire.
300 milliards de dettes. Et puis
maintenant, le gouvernement chinois
trouve que la réalité, c'est que je peux
vous dire que la situation financière
de la Chine est une plus grande menace
pour sa survie que tout ce qu'elle
essaie de faire sur le plan militaire.
Mais on ne veut pas le voir. Seulement
maintenant, ça vous tombe et qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? Le lendemain, une autre
entreprise immobilière tombe en faillite
et l'effet de domino se donne.
Revenons revenons à la à la psychologie
des acteurs financiers.
On parlait de traire les entreprises,
traire les états, traire ou tondre les
particuliers.
Quelle est la psychologie de ces gens-là
? C'est c'est des mégalot. Quand on
discute avec eux, ça nous est arrivé
d'être un petit peu infiltré pour voir
leur conversation de couloir. Ils ont
cette psychologie qui est le nivellement
par le bas, c'est pas pour nous,
l'égalitarisme, c'est pas pour nous.
Vous vous rendez bien compte qu'il se
battent pour des rouleaux de PQ et des
pots de Nutella, ils méritent leur sort.
Est-ce qu'il y a pas une sécession
dramatique des élites et une perception
entre guillemets du pauvre qui est
l'équivalent de l'esclave autant de de
l'esclavagisme ?
Si nous ne cassons pas l'idéologie qui
est derrière
en faisant en sorte que la population
s'en rende compte, que l'on se rend
compte vers quoi on va tout ce dont on
ne nous on ne nous parle jamais. Si on
n'éduque pas la finance, il va pas y
avoir de réaction. La psychologie de ces
gens-là, elle est extraordinaire. Je
vais vous donner un exemple. Elle est
fabuleuse.
JP Morgan,
très belle banque. Non, mais enfin,
c'est la plus belle banque probablement
du monde. Le discours dans la lettre du
chairman
dit c'est important que nous soyons là
pour aider les populations et cetera.
D'accord.
Il y a un mois, le conseil
d'administration annonce qu'on va donner
1 million et demi d'actions à ce pauvre
monsieur Jamie Diamond pour qu'il veut
bien continuer à rester. Il avait déjà
touché 32 millions de dollars de bonus.
Il vaut 2.9 milliards de fortune et il a
déjà 9 millions d'actions de JP Morgan.
Alors mon problème, il est là.
Sommes-nous dans une situation où
l'idéologie du capitalisme et je
j'insiste anglo-saxon
crée une forme de schizophrénie parce
que ce qui est très intéressant et je
les rencontre,
c'est extraordinairement
intéressant de voir qu'ils sont sincères
dans les deux cas
et si on ne leur met pas, j'allais dire
le nez dedans, vous pouvez le dire,
il est clair que ils ne vont pas s'en
préoccuper beaucoup.
Je pense à un grand assureur qui a fait
la même chose mais qui a refusé de payer
euh les les jours sans emploi des gens
qui étaient dans le dans le secteur des
restaurants.
On fait comment pour que
[raclement de gorge] la population son
s'en empare ? parce que notre petite
discussion entre nous, ça va pas faire
beaucoup par rapport à
ça va pas faire bouger
mais mais il on a cette capacité à à
esséer. Il faut quels sont vos conseils
pour le le Pékin lcendant comme nos
gouvernements aiment à nous le rappeler
tous les jours ? Quel Quels sont vos
conseils pour s'en emparer ? Il faut
s'intéresser à quoi ? Il faut suivre
quoi ?
poser une très très bonne question.
La
le discours officiel
de ce que j'ai appelé la Sainte Alliance
des intérêts, donc qui comprend aussi
bien le secteur public que le secteur
privé
est un discours
qui a pour objectif de vous dire "Ne
regardez pas, il y a rien à voir. Tout
va très bien, ne vous en faites pas, la
reprise est là, tout va bien." D'accord
?
Le peuple n'y croit pas.
C'est du pipo.
Mais mais le mais le peuple le sait que
c'est du pipo. Seulement, qu'est-ce que
vous voulez qu'il fasse ? Alors, il y a
la deuxième étape par rapport à ça,
c'est
je suis obligé de vous le dire et vous
avez fait une excellente
émission où quelqu'un a parlé des trois
fonctions
de la presse et une était d'être
complice.
D'accord.
Beaucoup beaucoup on dit ça Bernard
Stigler, sa fille. Voilà.
Barbara Stigler.
Barbara Stigler. D'accord. Bon, la
réalité c'est que le narratif public
étant ce qu'il est, y a-t-il un contre
narratif ?
Alors, j'ai pas besoin de vous donner la
structure de l'actionnariat des médias
en France.
Rappelons, on va le rappeler quand même
à nositeurs.
Ben écoutez, Vivin des contrôle une
série d'organes de presse,
le groupe Yel avec le patron de Lazar
contourne un autre et vous avez donc
toute une série de choses où on se passe
des élèves qu'on blagardair
fondamentalement l'actionnariat des
médias officiels qui ne sont pas les
médias d'État. L'actionnariat
est un actionnariat de grands
entrepreneurs et parfois de grands
prédateurs.
Donc si vous prenez à parti de manière
violente un autre chef d'entreprise qui
fait partie de l'élite,
la mafia,
je prends l'élite parce que je suis
gentil euh de ceux qui font partie de
l'élite. Si vous prenez Oui, si vous
voulez si vous prenez à ce moment-là, je
peux vous dire qu'il va y avoir un petit
coup de téléphone qui va arriver de très
haut et qui va dire "Vous voulez bien
lâcher la prise sur monsieur Intel ?"
Et les médias, si on attaque trop le
gouvernement, vous croyez que le
ministre va pas décrocher son téléphone
et voir le propriétaire de l'entreprise
en lui disant dites donc le Figaro, vous
avez écrit ça et ça, vous pouvez quand
même un peu calmer le jeu, non ?
Mais ça ça je vais vous objecter là. Et
oui, mais que
l'indépendance des journalistes Oui,
oui, oui, oui, oui.
La charte de musique.
Alors, je vais dire deux choses
là-dessus. La première,
c'est que comme c'est une idéologie,
comme les entreprises disent la même
chose et comme les le gouvernement dit
la même chose, il faut une autre voix.
Et là, je vais dire quelque chose qui va
pas plaire à certains.
La gauche est morte et les syndicats
sont devenus inutiles.
Qu'est-ce qui vous reste ?
Il y a pas de contrepouvoir.
Vous êtes en train de gérer une une
présidentielle
different shades of blue.
Les différentes nuances de bleu
de bleu. C'est entre la droite et la
semi-roite et la plus droite et la moins
droite.
Donc ça veut dire que pendant ces 10
dernières années, parce que ça remonte à
peu près 10 ans, on pouvait imaginer
quand on a eu M terin, même s'il était
très bourgeois, on avait quand même un
pouvoir socialiste. Hollande ça
commençait déjà à être un tout petit peu
Jospin, il y avait pas grand-chose.
Hollande c'était pas vraiment dur. Moi,
je me souviens un des exemples pour moi
qui est le meilleur et qui explique la
faiblesse de l'État.
François Hollande dit "Les entreprises
pour des raisons concurrentielles ont
besoin de diard."
François Hollande convoque le MDEF et il
leur dit "Oui, vous me garantissez un
million d'emplois."
Le MEDF dit "Non, on a payé les 10
milliards."
C'est magnifique. C'est formidable.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez changer ?
Dans ce monde-là, le statut quo est une
belle solution. Mais s'ils réfléchissent
à ce qu'ils font au reste de la
population et je reviens à ce que vous
disiez.
Est-ce qu'on doit attendre les gilets
jaune ? C'est pas grand-chose à côté de
ce qui nous attend.
D'accord ? Parce que si vous allez avoir
une augmentation des denrées euh
alimentaires, si vous vous rendez compte
que vous ne pouvez plus payer votre
loyer, si vous vous rendez compte que
vous pouvez plus payer l'essence, que
vous pouvez payer l'éducation de vos
enfants,
le chauffage
ou le chauffage,
c'est quoi ça ?
Et donc nous sommes arrivés au plan au
point où la pandémie a fait révéler
et alors il y a une deuxième élément
mais là je vais pas m'étendre parce
qu'on est dans un tout autre domaine.
Vous regardez ensuite la distribution
des vaccins à travers le monde entre le
tir et les pays organiques. Nous prenons
le troisème vaccin.
Il y a des milliards de personnes qui
n'ont pas eu le premier.
Revenons, revenons
au Panama Paper, au Pandora Paper.
C'est le travail exceptionnel de l'ICIG,
le le travail exceptionnel de 600
journalistes.
Fantastique.
On on se retrouve avec des gens qui font
une sécession économique.
Il faut quoi ? Il faut les traduire en
justice. Il faut saisir leurs biens. Il
faut qu'on fasse des exemples à la
nord-coréenne.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Ils sont
intouchables.
Ils sont intouchables.
Ils sont intouchables. Pourquoi ? Parce
qu'ils sont nombreux et partout.
Virez un journaliste qui est un peu trop
à gauche quand vous êtes un mania de la
presse.
Oh, ça va faire les manchettes pendant
24 heures et puis c'est terminé.
D'accord.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire contre
600 journalistes qui sont à travers le
monde, qui ont fait une analyse et qui
arrivent avec les preuves de ce qu'ils
disent ?
Vous pouvez rien faire ? Et c'est là que
j'ai l'espoir
parce que je crois qu'aujourd'hui il y a
un deuxième phénomène qui va se pré.
Donc il y a deux phénomènes pour le
moment qui me donnent quand même un
élément d'optimisme. Le premier et j'en
ai parlé déjà. Le premier, c'est qu'on
va enfin s'attaquer au problème de la
fiscalité des entreprises.
C'est tout le projet qui est en cours.
Et le deuxième, c'est que les banques
centrales vont commencer à diminuer
leurs interventions. En acheter moins,
disons. C'est pas ça pas dit qu'ils vont
pas en acheter. Mais c'est déjà ça va
dans le bon sens. Mais le troisème pour
moi qui est absolument fantastique et
qui est la revanche de la démocratie,
c'est le climate change, c'est le
changement climatique.
Et soyons clair,
souvenez-vous de ce que l'on a osé dire
de Greta Thonberg. C'est scandaleux.
Absolument.
On l'a traité, j'allais dire bon d'une
manière inacceptable.
Elle est toujours là.
Et je vais vous donner un élément qui me
fait
réfléchir.
Vous savez qu'il y a des fonds dans
lesquels on peut investir et qui
investissent fondamentalement dans des
actifs environnement sociaux gouvernance
ce qu'on appelle ESG. Il représente
maintenant croissance considérable 7
tron donc 7000 milliards de dollars
une goutte d'eau
non
fun n'en représente que trois
c'est important 7 trion et ça ne fait
que monter
7 trion 7000 milliards
7000 milliards
donc quelque part maintenant non
seulement la population a pris
conscience des risques mais ceux qui
veulent investir investir dans des fonds
communs et c'est en général des
particuliers
se dirige vers des actifs qui
choisissent cette orientation là au
détriment des autres. Et le résultat des
courses, allez voir le cours des
sociétés pétrolières.
Ils ont chaud en ce moment.
Ah, ils ont perdu 40 %. C'est pas
triste, hein.
Sauf que ils perdent 40 %. Donc ça, ils
ne peuvent plus faire de
l'investissement sur du du des pu de
pétrole.
parce que ça ça va être compliqué aussi
le sevrage énergétique des énergies
fossiles. On parlait de du de la dette
mondiale qui était plus de 200000
milliards
260000 milliards
de de de dollars. Cette dette
futurs impôts, c'est des promesses de
travail futur, c'est une dette par
rapport à la terre, à aux matières
premières qu'on va extraire. Est-ce que
cette dette ne va pas être répudiée
comme ce qui est marqué noir sur blanc
dans la Constitution américaine pour la
répudiation de la dette ? Est-ce qu'il
faut répudier les dettes ? Est-ce que
c'est possible ?
Est-ce que la signature des États va
pouvoir Je vous suis, je dirai les
choses de manière extrêmement claire. La
réputation de la dette, c'est un crime
contre les prêteurs.
C'est un crime.
Les les États-Unis pas
ils ne vous changeront jamais.
C'est un crime. Celui qui a prêté en
prenant des obligations d'un état l'a
fait de bonne foi. Il a droit au
remboursement.
Alors si vous voulez supprimer l'état de
droit, vous commencez à faire et c'est
pour ça que les gens bien intentionnés
qui ont été racontés que la Banque
centrale européenne allait finalement
supprimer la dette des États et tout le
bas n'ont absolument pas compris que la
Banque centrale européenne a deux de
côté de son bilan. D'un côté, elle a
toute cette dette. Mais qui est-ce qui
les finance ? Toutes les banques, les
banques centrales, les compagnies
d'assurance et cetera. Vous coupez ça,
vous mettez les banques en en faillite,
les compagnies d'assurance, les banques
centrales étrangères ne vous font plus
confiance et cetera. vous détruisez
fondamentalement
toute valeur. Et donc c'est pour ça que
les solutions de facilité ne sont pas
bonnes. Et c'est pour ça que dans mon
livre, ce que j'ai essayé de faire quand
je parle de l'exacerbation des
inégalités
dans ce livre, j'ai essayé d'aller de
manière fine, c'est-à-dire non pas le
grand discours populiste, il a un gros
avantage, il sonne bien, il a un gros
inconvénient, c'est qu'il est
profondément malhonnête.
Je m'excuse de le dire tel qu'il est
quand il n'est pas haineux.
Bon, par contre, si vous voulez faire
bouger les choses, vous devez travailler
sur les banques centrales, changer leur
politique. Vous devez faire que les
entreprises ne rachètent plus leurs
actions, sauf si elles en ont vraiment
besoin. Ils comprennent que quand elles
rachètent leurs actions, elles disent
"Je suis incapable de croîre." C'est un
aveu de faiblesse qu'elle qu'on cesse de
rémunérer les dirigeants des entreprises
de la même manière que les actionnaires,
que l'on travaille sur euh tout ce qui
peut faire le financement climatique,
des retraites, des soins de santé, c'est
tous ces éléments-là.
Et sur chacun de ces éléments,
la démocratie a prise. Mais si vous
voulez essayer de changer le système, il
se passera jamais rien.
Est-ce qu'on a le temps ? Oui.
Est-ce que Est-ce qu'on n'est pas à la
veille d'un cataclysme financier qui va
nous empêcher de faire tout ça ?
Attention, on a du temps pour faire ces
mesures-là. Là où je ne peux pas vous
répondre, c'est euh demain matin en nous
réveillant, nous ne découvrons pas que
la bourse a baissé de 50 % et que c'est
le 25. Il y a aujourd'hui par rapport au
montant en présence absolument aucun
parfeu qui tienne. Vous ne pourrez rien
faire contre 260000 milliards ou 60
milliards de dette souffra.
Pour résumer trivialement, on est en
short.
Le marché est short et la croissance
elle a été financée par la dette. Elle
n'a pas été financée autrement. Travail
mais que vous voulez. Mais exactement,
mais c'est c'était une façon en fait de
se soustraire des des fondamentaux de
soutenabilité d'une vraie économie.
C'était c'était de la poudre de Perlin
Pimpin, de la cocaïne monétaire et
c'était surtout une voie de facilité
pour les partis politiques qui eux aussi
ont des dettes auprès de certaines
banques qui leur prêtent le flanc pour
pouvoir passer leur propre loi. Là,
est-ce qu'on va avoir un homme d'état ou
des hommes d'état
qui vont essayer de se
passer moi l'expression mais de se
sortir les doigts et d'y aller de se
retrousser les manches ? Je dirais que
celui ou celle qui aura le gros courage
de devenir un homme d'état doit accepter
qu'il est possible
qu' perde sa tête
qu'elle se saorde.
Quand on est le pape francis, comme à la
fin de mon livre, quand on est le pape
François, on peut se permettre de dire
un certain nombre de choses sur les
marchés. quand on est ce genre de leader
là, un MD là des gens comme ça et je
crois qu'il doit y en avoir encore mais
aujourd'hui ce que nous asisons à la
tête de nos États et nous devons nous
poser la question ce ne sont pas des
gens dans dont nous avons une profonde
conviction d'intégrité hein.
C'est dramatique.
Enfin je m'excuse de vous dire un
exemple français mais le le dernier en
date.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette manie de
de de tapis ?
Le type est un forband.
D'accord. Et alors on lui trouve tout
des choses. C'est on va pas le mettre au
pantthéon.
Il est flamboyant.
Oui, mais ça veut dire que nous sommes
prêts à pardonner aux personnages
flamboyants n'importe quel crime.
Et quand nous en sommes là, alors la
question que vous posez, c'est-à-dire,
il y a-t-il des leaders charismatiques
qui sont vraiment des hommes d'état ou
des femmes d'état qui sont véritablement
des gens qui ont un message qui peut
aider la population, non pas en lui
faisant peur parce que la pandémie,
d'accord ? Moi ce que j'ai ressorti dans
mes blocs du monde par rapport à la
pandémie, c'est une citation de Gbels.
C'est ou
faites peur au peuple et vous pourrez
faire absolument tout ce que vous
voulez. Et on nous a fait peur
quand on nous a dit que nous ne pouvons
pas recevoir plus de x personnes dans
notre maison, on a dit quelque chose de
parfaitement inconstitutionnel et
illégal.
Si la force publique venait vous le vous
prendre dans votre maison, elle n'en a
pas le droit. Il faut une commission
rogatoire par rapport à un crime.
Mais on a eu peur. On a tous eu peur. On
devenait même l'élément de délation du
voisin tellement on avait peur. Et on a
vu réapparaître cet autoritarisme. Et
c'est là que je me dis il faut
effectivement faire émerger des gens qui
ont autre chose à dire et qui sont
capables de le gérer.
Et malheureusement,
nous sommes dans pas mal de pays
dans une situation dans laquelle il y a
de tel clivage que même les États-Unis à
l'intérieur du parti démocrate sont en
danger parce que les libéraux comme on
les appelle aux États-Unis sont des gens
irresponsables.
Par contre, les démocrates du centre
sont des gens qui sont responsables et
donc il y a par rapport à ça un
désaccord complet.
Et Biden là-dedans, il essaie de trouver
des mesures dans lesquelles il parvient
à obtenir un consensus politique, mais
il l'obtient pas dans son propre parti.
On peut raconter tout ce qu'on veut
aussi sur les républicains de Trump et
c'est horrible. Mais si à ce moment-là
vous mettez un homme dit de gauche au
pouvoir et que son extrême gauche
rend son action irresponsable et
impossible,
que faites-nous ? Ça ça nous ça nous
augure pas de de
beau de beaux jours devant nous. On n'
pas d'homme d'état, on n' pas la
capacité de les mettre au pas. On se
retrouve avec des
une population qui est bercée dans les
les doux rêves de tout va bien aller.
Voter pour moi, je suis le président du
pouvoir d'achat et je continue et je
continue. On voit la droite française
courir derrière des mesures populistes
que les populistes sont en train de
d'imposer.
On se retrouve avec un climat qui se
dérègle et une finance qui est
complètement déconnectée de la réalité.
Je vous parle des matières premières et
ainsi de suite. Là pour l'instant, on n'
pas la boucle d'accélération
inflationniste que sur les que sur les
actif financier qui ne profit qu'à qu'à
laer classe, la la toute petite franche
des 0,01 %. Mais quand l'accélération
monétaire va arriver dans les assiettes,
qu'est-ce qui nous au nez ? Vous avez
cité Gbles, on va se retrouver avec des
des des gouvernements totalites, un peu
partout et on sera coincé.
La finance, qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire
avec ça ? Elle va pousser les
gouvernements totalites, elle va
financer. Vous avez une idée de de à
quelle sauce on va se faire manger ?
Je ne suis pas pessimiste, aussi
étonnant que ça puisse paraître.
Mais parce que vous êtes
d'abord parce que nous avons le droit de
le dire
encore
et donc je ne pense pas que nous allons
vers la dictature même si les pouvoirs
occidentaux sont devenus un peu plus
musclés et un peu plus nationalistes.
Je vous ai dit qu'il y avait des
domaines dans lequels les réactions
étaient en piste. Vous savez, je
m'occupe pour le moment de choses
parfois étonnantes. essayer de trouver
les financements nécessaires pour mettre
en route une activité qui va faire du
diagnostic
des centres de traitement et de données
pour le cancer en Inde.
85 % des gens qui sont diagnostiqués,
c'est trop tard, ils ne sont nulle part.
Il y a énormément de bonnes choses qui
se passent et je voudrais qu'on en
parle. Allez,
je parle de l'éducation.
On va lancer la semaine l'année
prochaine en France chez un éditeur
français une série pour les lycéens de
livres qui sont écrits par des gens qui
savent de quoi ils parlent sur les
éléments de la finance et de l'économie
parce que c'est au lycée qu'il faut
apprendre ça. Une fois qu'on est à
l'université, on se spécialise
et donc il faut prendre une attitude
d'action et on revient sur Gamchi. Nous
sommes intellectuellement pessimistes,
mais dans l'action, il faut que nous
restions optimistes et il faut continuer
à essayer jusqu'au moment où on vous
arrêtez.
Et je crois que la leçon de la situation
que l'on vient de vivre, c'est que quand
on arrête tout,
c'est vraiment problématique. Et donc
maintenant, il faut s'assurer que la
dans le débat politique, on ose parler
de ce type de problème là et pas aux
États-Unis du problème de l'avortement
ou ici de monsieur Zemour.
On doit quand même parvenir d'une
manière ou d'une autre avec les médias,
avec
tous les leaders d'opinion, parvenir à
dire qu'il y a des problèmes sérieux qui
méritent de solution et demander à ceux
qui veulent être élus comment ils vont
résoudre ces problèmes et pas bloquer
l'immigration parce qu'on veut bloquer
l'immigration. On a des problèmes
beaucoup plus fondamentaux dans notre
société que le problème de savoir si on
peut prendre 10000 ou 20000 rien.
Même si c'est un sujet extrêmement
sensible et je le sais.
Bon, on fait une petite apartée sur le
marché des matières premières.
Oui, je vous écoute.
Comment vous voyez le marché les marchés
des matières premières ? C'est de la
spéculation, c'est pas de la
spéculation, c'est un retour de bâton de
toutes ces injections de liquidité.
C'est une pénurie, c'est pas une
pénurie. Qu'est-ce qui se passe sur le
marché des matières premières ?
On pourra en parler pendant 2 heures.
Donc je vais essayer d'être schématique.
Non non non,
il y a d'abord
prenez prenez votre temps et ne tombez
pas dans le simple et court.
D'accord.
Le problème c'est et vous le savez
puisque vous avez travaillé dans ce
marché le dire
le terme
du marché des matières premières couvre
des réalités extraordinairement
différentes.
Je m'explique.
Vous parlez du pétrole et du gaz.
Nous sommes dans le domaine de
l'énergie.
Il est certain qu'il y a des problèmes
d'approvisionnement.
Mais il ne justifie en rien la hausse du
prix de l'argent et surtout
ce qui moi m'amène toujours comme
connaisseur des marchés. La rapidité des
fluctuations, ça ressemble furieusement
à des à des paquets de traders.
Alors si on enlève les crêtages
spéculatifs,
alors il y a là des problèmes sérieux à
régler, nous sommes d'accord mais ça ne
va pas nous empêcher de vivre. nous
allons continuer à avoir du pétrole
russe. Alors, on a des problèmes
politiques avec les Russes, d'accord ?
Et il y a un pip qui ne fonctionne pas.
Enfin, la Commission européenne va
commencer à discuter avec les Russes
parce qu'on ne va pas quand même se
créer un problème énergétique parce
qu'on aime pas la manière dont les
Russes mettent le pipel. Il faut trouver
un accord, on s'en occupe. Il y a
deuxième catégorie très importante qu'on
appelle, je ne connais pas le terme en
français, les rear he. Ce sont des
métaux qui sont extrêmement peu nombreux
mais qui sont absolument essentiels au
semi
pardon
les terres rares.
Les terres rares qui sont essentiels
bien sûr au téléphone bien sûr au
semiconducteur mais maintenant on
découvre que c'est essentiel pour les
voitures et donc on est en train de se
rendre compte que le marché de
semiconducteurs qui vit de ces matières
premières est dans une situation où il y
a effectivement une insuffisance.
Résultat, plusieurs pays ont commencé à
lancer des activités
de dans ce domaine là, mais vous n'allez
pas changer la production de cobalt.
Et là, il y a un problème de gestion.
Pourquoi ? Parce que personne n'y pense.
On dit "Ah mais c'est tous les Chinois.
Le grand producteur de cobalt, c'est la
République démocratique du Congo."
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport
à ça ? Quel dialogue a-t-on dans un pays
? totalement pauvre.
Vous avez ensuite ce que j'appellerais
les matières industrielles. Là, on est
sur le fer, le zinc et cetera, tous les
matériaux.
Et là, on est sur des choses normales.
C'est-à-dire que s'il y a une
accélération de la demande, il va y
avoir une hausse des prix.
Mais n'oublions pas que ce sont des
matiers qui avant la pandémie ont
pendant la pandémie pardon ont perdu
énormément de leur valeur. Donc ils sont
occupés à récupérer. Donc il faut
prendre une vue à long terme. Donc dans
ces trois catégories on n' pas la même
réponse et on n' pas la même action mais
la réalité c'est que nous sommes
dépendants de beaucoup de choses. Je
vais parler d'un secteur qui est
important qui est le secteur
alimentaire.
Où en sommes-nous sur le secteur
alimentaire ?
Comment faisons-nous parvenir les
aliments ? Comment assurons-nous qu'il
soit propre ? Comment assurons-nous
qu'il soit
cultivé de manière convenable ? Ça vaut
pour le lait et cetera.
et que l'essentiel
ne soit pas de mettre les agriculteurs,
de pousser les agriculteurs au suicide,
mais de poser la question de la chaîne
qui elle fait que on passe de 10
centimes à 2 € le litre.
Donc il va falloir se poser cette
question là dans l'agriculture et
cetera. Mais mais ça ce sont des vrais
et c'est là voyez-vous que je trouve que
les États ne font pas leur métier. Ils
s'occupent de nous expliquer qu'il faut
un masse de plus, qu'il faut un truc de
ça et des choses comme ça.
Planification, c'est ça ?
Il faut et à long terme seulement les
marchés vous font une pression à court
terme constamment. Et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut rééquilibrer. Il faut que les
entreprises parlent du long terme, que
les entreprises expliquent ce qu'elles
vont faire pour investir et ne se
contentent pas de mots. Hier quand une
télévision où je parlais, j'ai vu le
dirigeant le patron d'Arceller Mital
c'est la sidérurgie ou sidérurgie
l'acier c'est horrible. 10 milliards de
dollars d'investissement dans les 10
prochaines années pour décarboner le
problème de la production de l'acier.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'il y a une technique
électrique qui existe pour l'acier et ce
ne sont plus les au fourneaux qui
doivent le fournir
qui eux sont en point de vue
environnement extraordinaire. Bon mais
voilà une entreprise qui pense long
terme
qui n'a pas le choix.
Elle n'a pas le choix mais elle le fait,
elle le précise et elle dit clairement à
ses actionnaires, "Je vais devoir
investir 10 milliards." Renault dit
"Pour pour l'entreprise, pour le
véhicule électrique, je vais devoir euh
utiliser investir 10 milliards."
D'accord ?
Si vous êtes un actionnaire, vous vous
posez la question ou bien vous vous
dites dans les prochaines années, il va
peut-être y avoir des des résultats
moins importants, vous vous taillez,
vous vendez vos actions. Très bien.
Aucune importance.
Si vous êtes un investisseur à long
terme, vous dites extraordinaire parce
que le Renault dans 10 ans ou l'arcè
orbital dans 10 ans, ça va être beaucoup
plus intéressant, plus profitable et
surtout beaucoup plus sain.
Ouais. On croise les doigts. Si si
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas être
pessimiste.
Euh revenons, on va en ouvrir encore une
autre parenthèse. Est-ce que vous vous
rappelez du scandale de Le Ribor et du
Ribor
? Oui.
Et de du Libor. Ouais.
Et du Libor, pardon.
Ouais. Et euh est-ce que vous pouvez le
résumer succintement à notre à nos
auditeurs et puis après on va rentrer
plus dans le détail.
Il était devenu indispensable à partir
du moment où le marché américain le
marché du dollar n'était plus aux
États-Unis.
mais était dans les euromarchés,
c'est-à-dire le marché du dollar en
dehors des États-Unis, il fallait un
taux d'intérêt de référence. Ça n'avait
évidemment aucun sens que ce soit un
taux
différent pour les Anglais, les Chinois,
les Japonais et cetera.
On a donc mis en place un système
à Londres en 11h tous les jours, on
fixait un London Interbank Offer Trade,
un taux offert à Londres entre les
banques
tous les jours.
Les crédits
qui se sont fait, les prêts aux
entreprises ont commencé à se faire à
taux variable
et pas à taux fixe parce qu'il y avait
pas assez d'argent taux fixe. Et c'est
pas un problème.
Et donc on empruntait au Libor plus ou
moins une marge et il y en avait pour
300 triom
taux de référence.
Ce m'envoie là, c'était géré par
l'Association Britannique des banques et
il y avait h banques qui faisaient le
marché
et un trade téléphoné en disant "Tu sais
aujourd'hui j'ai besoin qu'il soit deux
deux points de base plus élevés et
cetera" et ils ont commencé à manipuler
le marché.
Et la raison pour laquelle le Ribor et
le Libor ont explosé, c'est pas parce
que c'était des mauvais indicateurs,
c'est parce qu'ils ont été corrompus par
ceux là-mêmes qui devaient les maintenir
et qui sont occupés à pleurer toutes les
larmes de leur corps parce qu'ils
avaient une rente de situation
extraordinaire et maintenant ils vont en
être privés parce qu'évidemment on ne va
pas leur rendre
la responsabilité d'un marché qu'ils ont
eux-mêmes corrompu.
Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres marchés qui
sont manipulés ? Est-ce que le marché de
l'or est manipulé ?
Le marché de l'or est manipulé.
Le marché de l'argent est manipulé.
Bien sûr. Et et je dirait ceci.
Comment ?
Je vais prendre l'or et puis on va
peut-être parler du Bitcoin parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de confusion. Qu'on parle
du Bitcoin. Il y a parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de confusion par rapport à ça.
Alors l'or,
le premier stock d'or et le plus
important est détenu par les banques
centrales. Vous vous souvenez qu'on
vient d'un système dans lequel laée
était créée avec de l'or. Bien.
Quand j'étais jeune banquier, j'ai
beaucoup travaillé au Moyen-Orient.
J'aimais bien aller dans les souces
en Arabie Saoudite à Kouette
et les femmes
tout en rubané,
il y avait toute une série
de boutiques d'or.
Il y avait un élément électronique qui
était le prix de l'or à la seconde.
Alors vous allez dire "Mais c'était des
bijoux.
L'or c'était au poids et c'était leur
dot.
Et donc elles vendait, elles achetaient.
Il y a tout ce qui dans l'or arrive dans
la joie.
3è élément, il y a des besoins de l'or
comme élément de matière première par
rapport à l'industrie
et donc l'or joue ce rôle là. Et puis il
y a l'or, j'allais dire sur les marchés
trader.
Voilà.
Et
le résultat c'est que l'or a une
substance, il a une raison d'être et il
contient des éléments physiques. On ne
sort pas les pépites d'or n'importe
comment, ça un coûte. Donc tout ça est
extraordinairement réel.
Et c'est là qu'on commet l'erreur en
parlant du Bitcoin parce que le Bitcoin,
il a tout sauf ça. Il évidemment,
revenez sur
Mais restons sur l'or.
Est-ce que le marché est manipulé entre
l'or papier et l'or physique ?
Alors, il y a eu des périodes
l'or papier, vous savez,
je dirais que le plus gros
la plus grosse détention d'or papier et
ce qu'on appelle l'exchange traded fund.
Et il y a un très grand fond
seulement. Voilà ce qu'on oublie c'est
que l'exchange traded fund
qui vaut 50 milliards je crois peut-être
plus j'ai pas suivi les derniers
chiffres. Le le FT ouais peut-être
la règle de le de l'ETF
c'est que vous devez avoir les actifs en
dessous. Ça veut dire quoi ? Le problème
numéro 1 aujourd'hui, c'est que comme ce
fond est à Singapour, il y a
zéro contrôle.
Il y a Non, pas du tout. Il y a un
paquet d'or physique
qui est immobilisé dans les coffres à
Singapour pour couvrir l'encours des
ETF.
Mais les ETF émettent des certificats,
on va dire 1 pour 10.
Oui, mais ça n'a pas aucune espèce
d'importance. Ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance. La réalité c'est que la
définition d'un ETF c'est qu'il y a un
actif derrière. Un ETF en action.
Est-ce qu'ils sont audités ces ETF ?
Oui, ils sont complètement réguliers et
croyez-moi, s'ils se départissent de la
valeur des actifs sous-jacent,
automatiquement le marché corrige ou
bien il leur arrive une petite culbute.
Donc par rapport à ça, le TF c'est
simplement de mettre une série d'actifs
ensemble et de vous donner un papier qui
représente ensemble des actifs. Dans le
cas de ce fond là, il n'y a qu'un seul
actif de l'or sous différentes formes.
Cet or papier est exactement la même
chose puisque l'émetteur
de l'ETF doit avoir l'or en sa
possession.
C'est bien doit avoir l'or. Je vous
reprends le le rappelez-vous le marché
du chocolat.
Ah
oui, ça je connais pas.
Le le
J'ai jamais jamais tradé dans le
chocolat.
Le admettons, un investisseur a tout le
le marché du chocolat dans sa poche.
Oui.
Et il demande livraison. Oui,
ça a été compliqué aux ETF de livrer
quand même.
Ben les ETF du chocolat, c'est trop
froid rien
hein. Mais sur les ETF d'or, c'est
Mais par contre, regardez les ETF sur le
plan notamment et vous avez tout le
marché dans l'agriculture, du blé et
cetera et ça ça se traite tous les jours
et c'est principalement à Chicago et à
Paris et dans d'autres pays.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand on demande
la livraison ?
Bah vous vous livrez et vous déteignez
les choses.
Et des fois on demande la livraison mais
il y a pas derrière.
Si si vous n'avez
je vous dirai ceci, je prendre
l'exemple.
Imaginons que vous ayez des ETF et que
vous ayez l'équivalent d'une tonne d'or
sous forme de papier.
Vous rendez le papier,
le gestionnaire du fond va vous donner
l'or en livraison physique.
Il l' ça lui pose pas de problème. Et le
prix auquel il vous le donne, si à ce
moment-là vous recevez l'or et que l'or
se casse la figure, vous allez perdre de
l'argent sur votre stock d'or.
Donc il y a une livraison physique,
c'est la même chose dans toute une
partie du trading des matières
premières, y compris le pétrole, il y a
des livraisons physique.
Le marché de l'argent manipulé, pas
manipulé.
Écoutez, pour moi, il y a un vrai
problème sur l'ensemble du marché marché
des marchés des matières premières qui
remonte à toutes les distorsions qui ont
eu lieu dans la pandémie. D'accord ?
Pour faire cour, la manière dont on
transporte tout ça ne se fait plus bien.
Il y a des problèmes de pipeline avec
les Russes. Il y a ceci, il y a ça. On
remet les pendule à l'heure. Il y a des
frictions.
Ces frictions commencent à poser un
certain nombre de problèmes.
Vous êtes un trader, vous vous dites
"Oh, ces frictions vont faire monter le
prix parce que ça va coûter plus cher
d'avoir le gaz." Qu'est-ce que vous
faites ? Vous vous mettez en position à
la hausse du gaz.
Ce matin, il paraît que l'or a monté que
l'argent a monté de 25 % et puis
rebaissé de 10 %.
C'est pas un problème de livraison de
gaz, c'est un problème de trading
le parasite.
Mais évidemment,
on parle de croissance, de croissance de
croissance.
Si on rentre en décroissance, qu'est-ce
qui va se passer sur les marchés
financiers ?
Ah, c'est une très bonne question.
J'étais à Montréal il y a 3 ans
ou à la conférence de Montréal pu une
très grande conférence et j'étais sur un
panel
où j'ai dit je ne suis pas sûr que la
croissance est nécessaire partout.
Inutile de dire que les autres
financiers du panel me sont tombés
dessus en disant il y a rien sans la
croissance et cetera. Alors moi
maintenant je vais reculer. Je vais vous
parler du Japon.
On n pas beaucoup d'enfants au Jon.
La population est âgée.
Il y a pas d'immigration. Elle et on
refuse d'immigration. Donc la population
japonaise est en train de descendre vers
80 millions de personnes venant de
s'enre.
Le problème
c'est pas la croissance, c'est le revenu
par habitant. Non.
Si vous diminuez le nombre d'habitants,
avez-vous besoin de la même croissance ?
Parce que si vous avez besoin de la même
croissance, ça va être un
enrichissement.
Donc c'est pas nécessairement un pouvoir
d'achat.
Et donc à partir du moment où vous avez
une fonction, ce fonctionnement est une
baisse de la population,
le Japon peut se permettre d'avoir une
croissance quasiment zéro et les
Japonais s'emporteront bien.
Par contre, vous êtes un pays en voie de
développement
et vous avez une population qui gagne
trois fois rien et je prends l'Europe de
l'Est. L'Europe de l'Est a vécu à cause
du communisme et cetera à des niveaux
extrêmement bas. L'Europe de l'Est doit
connaître une forte croissance et on
oublie de le dire, nous n'avons pas de
croissance en Europe de l'Ouest mais on
a une très forte croissance en Europe de
l'Est. Dans les pays en véveloppement,
il y a une forte croissance.
En Inde, on parle de 8 %. En Chine, on
parle de 6 %. Chez nous, on pense qu'on
fera 2 %. C'est wishful thinking.
Et donc la raison ce que j'essaie de
dire, c'est que la croissance est vitale
pour des pays dans un certain stade de
leur croissance. Pour nous, le problème
c'est le pouvoir d'achat. Si à ce
moment-là le gâteau n'augmente pas, il
faut s'assurer qu'il soit bien réparti.
Retour à la case départ de notre
discussion.
Exactement. Ouais.
Question internet.
E Ribor, des gens sont-ils en prison
pour avoir manipulé les cours ?
Oui.
Beaucoup ? Pas beaucoup.
Pas beaucoup.
Quel type de peigne ils ont reçu ?
Oh, ils ont reçu quelques années de
prison, ils sont sortis. Oh, magnifique.
Ce ce
la plusvalue est acceptable.
Non, eux n'ont pas gagné d'argent, hein,
du tout. C'est leur banque qui a gagné
de l'argent. Par contre, les banques ont
sérieusement payé des amendes.
N'oublions pas que c'est une peine
physique, une peine monétaire. On a tué
personne. Donc cet élément là qui a joué
et il y a eu des poursuites judiciaires
qui font qu'un certain nombre de banques
ont dû dédommager les gens qui en
avaient souffert.
Ça a tué personne. Je dirais oui et non.
Parce que on va dire que le le Bulgare
qui a souscrit son emprunt qui était
adossé sur du Libor
et qui pouvait pas rembourser et qui
s'est suicidé derrière,
ça tue quand on manipul.
C'est pas par c'est pas à cause du
Libor.
C'est à cause du qui ? Parce que j'ai
envie de vous dire que ce dont nous
parlons,
c'est éventuellement que le taux du jour
au lieu d'être 209 8 va être 208.
Ça change pas l'équation mais par contre
sur les masses ça fait des milliards.
Et donc c'est extrêmement difficile pour
le BGA dont vous parlez de savoir qu'il
a effectivement payé 0,01 % de plus
d'intérêt que ce qu'il aurait lu si le
marché n'avait pas été manipulé. Pour ça
qu'il y a pas de poursuite. Donc le
Libor font maintenant retrouver quelque
chose d'ussi fort. Les banques traînent
les pieds. Non pas parce qu'elles
veulent retourner au Libor. Elles
connaissent le problème du Libor mais
c'est parce qu'on ce qu'on propose comme
alternative n'est pas robuste. Et elles
ont horriblement peur qu'il y ait de la
volatilité à ce moment-là dans
l'ensemble du marché des crédits. Et
comme on parle, comme je vous l'ai dit,
de 300000 milliards en plus ou moins à
travers le monde, je comprends.
Et quand une banque a prêté, je sais
pas, 10 ou 20 milliards, ça peut avoir
un impact considérable non seulement sur
elle, mais sur son client.
Question internet, un petit mot avis sur
les chambres de compensation et de leur
rôle actuel entre parenthèses à faire
clearstream.
Alors, l'affaire clearstream, ça c'est
une des plus grandes farces de de
l'année.
Dites-moi pourquoi.
Parce que Clearstream n'a pas de client
particulier.
Clearstam est une chambre de
compensation entre intermédiaires
financiers.
On n jamais dit ça et je sais que ce qui
s'est passé avec de Ville Pain toute la
clique. D'accord. Et il y a eu des
manœuvres qui ont eu lieu et elles sont
peut-être frauduleuses, je n'en sais
rien. Mais il ne faut pas croire que
vous pouvez ouvrir un compte chez
Clearstream demain matin.
C'est pas une banque. Ça sert de
compensation entre institutions
financières parce que tu me dois un
milliard, je te dois 100 millions, on va
faire le truc à 900 et ça se compense à
l'intérieur de cette chambre de
compensation. Mais c'est un truc qui se
situait entre professionnel et donc la
soi-disant les soi-disants listing faux
qu'on a publié dans lequel on dit on a
supprimé le nom de monsieur Sarkozy ou
de monsieur Vilpin et cetera, c'était
défaut. Il y a pas de listing sur des
individus chez Clairstream, ça n'a
jamais existé et ça n'existera jamais
parce que c'est pas son rôle.
Question internet. Que pensent-t-il du
système de création monétaire actuelle ?
Que suggèrent-il pour le rendre plus
éthique, égalitaire et solidaire ?
Le début de la question.
Alors, que pensent-il du système de
création monétaire actuel ?
Alors, le système de création monétaire
actuelle par les banques centrales crée
un double déséquilibre. Le premier,
c'est que les épargnants sont pénalisés
par rapport aux émetteurs et le deuxième
c'est que cet argent là en bourse, ça
crée une inégalité. Donc il faut
retourner à la case départ et dire aux
banques centrales de cesser parce qu'ils
ont peur de continuer à arroser le
marché, de commencer à diminuer la mise
et de voir s'il y a de véritables
problèmes. Les États-Unis avaient
commencé avant la pandémie et ça n'a pas
posé de problème et d'arriver
progressivement à trouver un équilibre
plus naturel, moins manipulé par les
banques centrales. Et à partir de ce
moment-là, on va avoir un équilibre.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'à ce moment-là, les
emprunteurs vont payer un vrai taux
d'intérêt et donc l'épargnant qui a une
obligation ou qui a un dépôt va recevoir
le rendement auquel il a droit sur son
dépôt. Et donc, il est indispensable que
le la monnaie facile qui facilite le
travail des emprunteurs s'arrête
en douceur. Il ne s'agit pas de faire
quelque chose qui va démolir les marchés
de telle manière que progressivement on
rééquilibre en faveur des épargnant, on
rééquilibre en faveur de l'emploi par
rapport à tout pour l'actionnaire et
qu'on retrouve dès lors
non pas en démolissant les marchés mais
en redonnant au marchés leur fonction
qui est essentielle. financer les
entreprises.
Quand vous étiez patron du New York
Stock Exchange, vous vous palpiez
combien ?
Pardon ?
Votre salaire c'est
400000 dollars
à l'année ?
Oui.
Après, avant impôt.
Avant impôt.
Ça été publié pour ça que je vous le
dis.
Euh de toute façon, vous nous l'auriez
dit même
pardon.
Vous vous nous l'auriez dit si c'était
pas publié.
Non. Non,
parce qu'à ce moment-là, je trouvais
dans le devoir voie de confidentialité
vis-à-vis du New York Stock Exchange,
mais comme le New York Stock Exchange a
publié la rémunération de ces
dirigeants,
je peux vous le dire.
Euh, vous stockez votre vos actifs,
votre cash dans quoi ? Si si on se tape
une dévaluation monétaire,
il faut il faut se positionner sur quel
type d'actif pour éviter de moins se
Alors, vous posez deux questions
différentes. Qu'est-ce que j'ai fait ?
Moi, j'ai quatre enfants.
Ils sont arrivés à cette époque là à la
phase universitaire. J'ai payé les
études. J'ai dû acheter de l'immobilier
aux États-Unis puisque il fallait que je
vive aux États-Unis. C'est un peu cher.
Donc, j'ai pas beaucoup épargné,
croyez-moi. Maintenant, dans une
situation comme celle-ci, maintenant,
il faut être extrêmement prudent.
Euh et en tout cas aujourd'hui,
il ne faut investir qu'à court terme ou
sur des actions d'entreprise à qui vous
faites confiance. Court terme, pourquoi
sur les obligations ? Parce que les taux
doivent monter et quand les taux vont
monter, votre valeur va baisser. Donc il
vaut mieux avoir, j'allais dire des
investissements 1 an, 2 ans ou des
choses comme ça. Par contre sur les
actions, il faut voir les entreprises
auxquelles vous croyez, celles qui vont
résoudre le problème climatique, celles
qui sont bien gouvernées et cetera,
mettez pas un fran chez Facebook, Amazon
et tous ces gens-là. Il faut vraiment
regarder qui sont et bien connaître. Et
je crois que dans le fond, dans ce dont
je parlais, c'est-à-dire c'est
extraordinairement aux croissance du
fond ESG, vous avez précisément des
sélections d'actifs qui sont faits par
les gestionnaires de ces fonds qui sont
les entreprises qui croient et qui se
gèrent en fonction d'une politique qui
respecte ses principes et vous allez
retrouver vos valeurs.
Parlons un peu des cryptos, les
cryptonnaies. Quel est votre avis sur
les cryptos ? C'est du vent, c'est pas
du vent ? Est-ce que c'est une façon de
se soustraire de la création monétaire
pilotée par les banques centrales, les
États, les politiques corrompuses et
j'en passé des meilleurs ou où c'est de
la poudre de perlin pimpin qui va être
stoppé net par la politique des États
qui ne peuvent pas se permettre de
perdre le contrôle de la monnaie ?
C'est beaucoup de questions. Première
question
euh
toute forme de crypto
euh de type Bitcoin, ne parlons pas des
stable coin parce que ça c'est autre
chose, est une fuite en dehors du
système. Donc c'est une fuite face à la
monnaie et donc c'est de l'argent qui
est perdu pour l'économie.
L'argent
des cryptos n'est pas réinvesti. On
ninvestit pas en crypto.
Donc leur utilité
est non social.
Deuxème élément,
ils n'ont pas derrière eux, comme l'on
des devises, une réalité économique que
vous pouvez estimer. Donc, vous savez
parfaitement que c'est un instrument de
réserve qui ne fonctionne qu'en fonction
de l'ordre et de la de l'offre et de la
demande.
Troisièmement,
il y a toute une série de j'appellerai
de forces sombres derrière qui trouvent
dans l'anonymat des Bitcoin les moyens
de frauder le fisque ou l'argent du
crime et cetera. Et donc euh
le je dirais à la limite le crypto doit
pas disparaître.
Il y a pas de raison de disparaître, il
représente pas grand-chose.
Et de toute façon, il ne faut surtout
pas que les banques centrales se lancent
dans une politique de monnaie numérique
comme elles sont occupées à essayer de
le faire sans se rendre compte du risque
systémique qu'elles vont faire porter au
système financier.
Pourquoi un risque systémique ?
Aujourd'hui, si vous voulez déposer de
l'argent en gros, vous allez le déposer,
aller à la BNP. D'accord.
Non, pas la BNP.
Je voulais je voulais choisir le le la
banque. Bien, je vous donne un exemple
d'une banque française connue qui bon
la poste.
Allez à la poste.
Demain,
vous allez pouvoir choisir entre ce
dépôt là ou
un e-currency, une i monnaie qui vaudra
également 1 € mais votre créant, votre
débiteur sera la banque centrale.
Vous me suivez ?
À partir de ce moment-là, que fait la
banque centrale avec cet argent ?
parce que cet argent n'est plus dans les
banques et ce qui n'est pas dans les
banques va affaiblir les banques
puisqu'elles auront moins de dépôts. Or,
nous savons tous que les dépôts sont
l'encours le plus important de la
stabilité du monde bancaire.
C'est pour ça que Macron a permis de
d'avoir des dividendes en fin d'année.
C'était pour bquer les banques.
Et ça c'est encore un autre problème
mais je suis d'accord avec vous. Dans ce
cette situation là,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Le propriétaire,
imaginons une crise,
je crois que c'est le meilleur exemple
crise pour prendre l'exemple qui ne
mentionne pas. La BNP tombe en faillite.
D'accord ?
On le souhaite pas.
On ne le souhaite jamais à personne.
Vous vous souvenez ce qui s'est passé en
Angleterre au moment de la crise
financière ? Vous allez à votre banque
et vous essayez d'avoir des billets.
Regardez l'bon
pour voilà pour essayer d'avoir quand
même de l'argent. Ici c'est beaucoup
plus facile. Vous transférez de la
banque à la banque centrale et la banque
centrale se trouve débordé
de milliards de dollars de dépôts de
tous les gens qui paniquent,
ne sait pas quoi en faire et puis à un
moment donné ça se calme et subitement
ça revient. Alors elle cherche à faire
quoi ? Comment va-t-elle connaître ses
clients ? Comment va-t-elle assurer que
ces clients ne font pas des opérations
malhonnêtes et qu'on n pas sur le
blanchissement d'argent ? Il y a toute
une série de mécanismes qui existent
dans les banques pour essayer de gérer
les dépôts. Les banques centrales sont
pas équipées pour faire ça. Et puis je
vous dis si à un moment donné ils ont
tout cet argent là, c'est pourquoi ?
Pour financer l'État.
La crise de 2008, on l'a bien vu,
l'argent de la drogue a baqué a baqué
les États et les banques. C'est que ça
ça a blanchi à tour de bras des milliers
de milliards
du tout.
Non non, ça a été un transfert massif
entre certaines institutions financières
et dans le cas de l'Europe, ça été un
transfert massif des banques italiennes,
espagnoles et cetera vers les banques
allemandes et les banques allemandes et
enant plus d'argent l'ont mis à la
banque centrale et la banque centrale a
reprêté aux banques espagnoles puisque
c'est son rôle. Donc on a fait un mai
gorant. Quand on fait ça, il y a une
chose qui change, c'est que le risque
est pris par la banque centrale et plus
directement entre banques parce que les
banques ne se font plus confiance. Une
banque centrale, ça peut tomber.
Une banque centrale, ça peut tomber de
manière théorique seulement. C'est la
même chose que la faillite d'un État.
Donc, les États ne tombent pas en
faillite, mais ils doivent restructurer
leur dettes. Ils doivent retrouver les
moyens que la Grèce a retrouvé
finalement pour pouvoir fonctionner.
C'est une crise importante mais c'est
pas une faillite. La seule chose que je
peux vous dire c'est que si vous
regardez les bilans des banques
centrales aujourd'hui, vous avez la
preuve qu'elle ne tombe pas en faillite
parce que si les ratios des banques
centrales étaient les mêmes que les
ratios bancaires, et ben la banque
centrale sans faillite, elle a
pratiquement pas de fond propre.
Protocole de balle 2, balle 3.
Oui, mais elle a heureusement quand même
de la monnaie en circulation.
Heureusement.
Le fond de garantie des dépôts
bancaires, ça vous parle ? Oui, ça me
parle. C'est un point important de du
dispositif des banques européennes.
Euh c'est-à-dire que dans le cadre de
l'Union bancaire européenne, il y a
trois piliers. Le troisème pilier, c'est
de créer un fond qui assure plus ou
moins, plutôt plus que moins
le une intervention en cas de crise de
crédit ou d'accord ?
Tous les pays ont ça. On va essayer de
mettre tout ça ensemble, de travailler
au niveau européen.
C'est pas un peu du bullshit ça ?
C'est pas du bullshit. Le problème que
c'est c'est que ça fait 10 ans qu'on
n'est pas parvenu à le résoudre.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il y a une raison
structurelle.
Moi, je vais vous dire ceci.
Si j'étais aujourd'hui le système
bancaire allemand, d'accord, et que je
dois mettre mes mes impôts de sécurité
dans un pot européen
et que pour prendre un exemple tout à
fait farfelu,
les banques grises se sont mis les
banques grecques se sont mis à spéculer
sur je ne sais quoi et tombe en
faillite. C'est l'argent des banques
allemandes qui va partir à la Grèce. Je
vous garantis que ça va avoir lieu une
fois et c'est pas une expression belge.
Après ça, le fond, il est fini, hein.
Donc ça a du sens mais le véritable
problème et je dirais qu'il faut bien
regarder ce qu'il y a aux États-Unis,
nous avons ce système là qui s'appelle
le FDIC, mais en cas de manque du fond,
il y a une garantie du gouvernement
fédéral.
Donc on en sortira si ce pool qui est
mis ensemble de ressources est
fondamentalement garanti par l'Union
européenne.
Donc si on active ce fond
qui est garanti par la signature soit
d'un État soit de l'Union européenne h
ce qui lui permet d'activer un effet de
levier sur les marchés. H
h
on est d'accord ? Hm
hm.
On l'active une fois mais on l'activera
pas deux.
Il faut voir ça dans le contexte aussi
du contrôle des banques par la banque
centrale européenne. Ils ne peuvent pas
faire n'importe quoi. Ils peuvent pas
faire une infraction à balle 3 et
cetera. Il peut y avoir des fraudes ou
n'importe quoi. Mais je dirais que c'est
ce qu'on appelle en langage technique un
backstop. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a
d'abord, mettons une masse de 100
milliards qui est là pour sauver et si
la le drame est 200 milliards, ben les
États vont intervenir pour 100 milliards
de plus. On va commencer par vider le
fond. Donc quelque part, le risque est
un risque que l'on appelle conditionnel
que dans le langage bancaire, on
mettrait en pied de bilan et pas dans le
bilan. Mais c'est un mécanisme de
garantie qui solidifie.
Mais
est-ce que nous pouvons, nous avons créé
un marché, une Union bancaire européenne
suffisamment robuste pour que ce risque
que je viens de dire, c'est-à-dire de
voir cet agent filer devant une action
parfaitement stupide d'un des
gouvernements ou d'une série de banques
soit extraordinairement limité.
Est-ce que vous pensez que le fond est
suffisamment provisionné ?
Et pour le moment, il n'existe pas. En
France, le fond de garantie des dépôis
le fond français garantit 72000 €. C'est
ça c'est tout autre chose entre vous et
moi. D'accord.
Le fond le fond a des provisions mais je
répète c'est un backstop.
Si la société générale perd 100
milliards règle le fond à 50 milliards,
je vous garantis que les 50 milliards
viendront du gouvernement
de notre poche.
Évidemment.
Est-ce qu'il faut pas les laisser tomber
ces banques ? Non, c'est pas ça qu'il
faut faire. Ce qu'il y a, c'est que il
faut que l'on ait un encadrement et des
réglementations de banque qui font
qu'elle ne prennente pas des risques
excessifs de telle manière que le fond
de garantie soit suffisant. Donc, c'est
en gérant bien les banques que le
problème va se résoudre et il faut les
laisser. Alors, la question de savoir si
vous laissez une banque tomber, ça c'est
le problème classique. On a laissé
tomber l'Iman Brothers mais ça a coûté
beaucoup d'argent. Question internet.
Après l'affaire Carviel, où en est-on
dans le contrôle des salles de marché ?
Le contrôle des salles de marché
a fait l'objet
d'un travail assez considérable au
niveau européen
et le système de reporting, donc de
donner les informations et de
transparence vis-à-vis des autorités de
contrôle s'est amélioré.
La deuxième chose, c'est que les
réglementations de balle 3, parce que
n'oublions pas que Carivant balle 3,
tenu compte d'un certain nombre de
leviers qui sont fermés. Donc, il y a un
certain nombre de choses qui ne pourront
pas se faire. Je reste pendant convaincu
que la faiblesse du système européen,
c'est que contrairement aux États-Unis
avec les fameuses règles volcaires qui
énervfent les banques, mais c'est très
bien qu'elles soit énervée, les banques
européennes n'ont pas encore interdit ce
qu'on appelle le proprietary trading.
Pourquoi ? Le proprietary trading, c'est
une banque qui utilise ses fonds propres
qui sont là pour garantir ses crédits en
allant spéculer sur des indices
boursiers. C'est ça qui s'est passé.
Dans mon jeune temps, pour parter comme
un vieillard,
le capital d'une banque était
entièrement investi en emprunt d'État.
Était pas question de spéculer. Ce qu'a
fait le plan Volcaire, c'est de
supprimer toute une série d'actifs euh
spéculatifs de ce que les banques
pouvaient prendre pour couvrir leur
fonds propres. C'est pas uniquement des
emprunts d'État. En Europe, on n pas cet
élément-là. On n pas cet élément là
parce que bah les banques n'aiment pas.
Et le problème c'est que les banques en
Europe sont beaucoup plus puissantes
qu'aux États-Unis.
Question internet. Que pense George de
l'art contemporain et des NFT non
fungible token ?
J'aime trop l'arc contemporain pour le
mettre dans un NFT. Si j'ai de l'argent
à mettre dans l'arc contemporain, je
préfère prendre une pièce d'un artiste
et la voir chez moi. Le NFT, c'est une
façon de créer des commissions pour les
intermédiaires.
Pratiquement, c'est titrisé là. Ouais.
Rien. Porte rien.
Question internet.
Que pense monsieur UGE ? Peut-il nous
expliquer les tensions passées et
futures sur les marchés interbancaires
du repos ?
Bon, alors pour ça, il faut faire une
toute petite explication sur ce que
c'est qu'un marché du Ripo. Et le marché
du RIPO, c'est un système dans lequel
les banques
vont utiliser une partie de leurs actifs
et vont les vendre avec un engagement de
rachat
ou les prêter si vous voulez avec un un
élément de rachat. ce qui leur permet
automatiquement d'avoir les liquidités
sans abandonner 3 mois après ou 6 mois
après ou une semaine après il le
reprennent.
Le problème du marché des ripos, c'est
que s'il y a la moindre tension ou la
moindre méfiance, sa liquidité
s'assèche immédiatement. C'est la
première chose qui s'assèche parce que
la confiance entre les banques n'existe
plus. Et donc nous avons vécu même
l'année dernière quelque chose qui n'a
pas attiré beaucoup d'attention et qui
est effectivement
une intervention brutale de la Fédéral
Reserve pour empêcher une crise de
marché des ripos. La question qu'on peut
se poser c'est pourquoi le bilan d'une
banque est à 50 % dans les crédits et 50
% dans toute une série d'autres choses ?
les pays à risque pour vous et les
banques à risque
quels sont pour vous les est-ce que la
par exemple la Dutch Bank est une banque
sûre ? Est-ce qu'il faut
mettre son argent dans des banques qui
ont l'habitude de gérer les crises
telles qu'on va les prendre ? Est-ce
qu'il faut aller mettre son argent chez
Rothshield ? Est-ce qu'il faut aller
mettre son argent chez Lazar ? Est-ce
qu'il faut prendre une banque qui a plus
de 200 ans qui a eu l'habitude de gérer
des choses tumultueuses ?
Alors,
le système de garantie des dépôts
de l'Union européenne qui fait que si
vous mettez 100000 €
dans une banque,
vous avez une garantie d'État qui fait
que de toute façon vous les retrouverez.
c'est 72000 maintenant. Excusez-moi.
C'est dommage qu'on est baissé.
Ça pouvait pas garantir en fait quand
vous vous preniez le fond et que vous le
divisiez en nombre de comptes bancair,
ça faisait pas beaucoup derrière. Donc
quand nous on a vu notre ministre des
finances, comment il s'appelait là le
[soupir]
le qui était un peu petit et un peu
trapu là,
sapin
[rires]
euh il nous a mis un effet de levier
parce qu'ils sont ils sont rendus compte
que le fond de garantie des dépôts
bancaires, les français comprenaient que
c'était du pipo.
Ben c'est une erreur, c'est pas du
pipot. C'est-à-dire que pour pour 90 %
ou 95 % de la population,
il y a pas 72000 € en banque.
Exact. et
ce n'est que dans les banques de dépôt.
Donc quand vous allez dans les
Rotschield et d'autres fonds, vous
n'avez pas cette garantie. Donc je vais
pas ça m'intéresse pas de savoir si
elles sont ceci, si elles sont ça. Si
vous voulez être sûr qu'un dépôt de
moins de 70000 ne vous sera jamais
enlevé, mettez-le dans une banque
classique.
Et à la limite, une petite ou une
grande, ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance puisque la réglementation,
c'est un certain montant par banque,
quelle que soit la banque,
c'est par compte et par établissement
bancaire.
Voilà.
On en est où avec la culture du machisme
incontrôlable dans la finance ?
Bon, si je comprends bien la question,
le machisme,
le patriarcat, tous ces mots
généralement quelconque, c'est donc un
problème
homme-femme. En gros,
c'est bien ça la question,
ça y ressemble bien.
Donc
où en sommes-nous ? La première chose
que je vais dire, c'est qu'on a fait des
progrès colossaux dans le système
financier.
Bah, vous partiez de loin, non ? Ça oui,
il y a des pratiques du genre offrir à
un collègue trader le stripties d'une
fille dans la salle de trading qui ne
sont plus tolérés.
On a plus le droit de se faire des
lignes de cô que sur des fesses. C'est
interdit ça.
C'est fini. Donc on a quand même fait un
petit eff. Ça ce n'est pas c'est du
détail.
Le machisme c'est un problème qui va
très au-delà du service financiers.
C'est une question de comportement de
l'individu, de son éducation et cetera.
Il y a des secteurs de la finance
[grognement] où il est plus prononcé que
dans d'autres.
J'ajoute une chose, il y a des secteurs
de la finance où les femmes ne veulent
pas aller
de peur ?
Non, pas nécessairement de peur d'un
mitou ou quelque chose comme ça, mais
parce que la culture telle qu'elle
fonctionne dans ce secteur là est
incompatible avec une vie de famille par
exemple.
Et donc il faut être nuancé quand on
fait l'analyse et bien entendu les
banques résolvent le problème en mettant
des chiffres en disant "J'ai autant de
femmes à tel niveau et cetera et cetera
mais ça ne dit rien."
La réalité c'est que je peux vous dire
que
si vous vous mettez dans une salle
avec quelques personnes dans un bureau
et je parle pas de trading ici n'importe
où. Si vous avez un machiste ou bien
vous le virez ou bien ça pollue toute
l'atmosphère du bureau.
Donc le véritable problème c'est le
problème de la sanction.
Est-ce que oui ou non certains
comportements, certains langages,
certaines attitudes sont ou ne sont pas
tolérables ? Et quand je dis le problème
des sanctions, ça veut donc dire que le
comportement après un avertissement ou
deux, c'est la porte.
Et à ce moment-là, on va arriver mais
c'est une mauvaise solution. C'est une
solution
pour mettre à la porte quelqu'un de
profondément immature. Finalement, c'est
un espèce de mec qui se prend pour je ne
sais quoi. Moi, j'ai jamais trouvé que
le machisme était intelligent. Je trouve
que les relations entre mes femmes sont
absolument fantastiques quand on est
égalitaire. Je suis avec la même femme
depuis 50 ans et c'est une femme forte,
courageuse et qui est psychanalyste.
Donc par rapport à ça, ça ne me c'est
quelque chose je peux pas comprendre ce
machisme là.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle pense la psychanalyste
du milieu bancaire ? Ben, elle pense du
milieu bancaire que euh
elle a une forte clientèle venant de
Wall Street.
Je crois que je préfère répondre de
cette manière-là.
On s'est compris. Si je vous dis vol de
mort, ça vous fait penser à quoi ? Ah
oui, ça me fait penser à au personnage
de de choses, hein, de C'est quoi ? De
Rowlings. Non, c'est c'est le les
anneaux ou c'est l'autre ?
Harry Potter. Harry Potter, c'est ça me
dit quelque chose. Oui, j'ai fait un
article d'ailleurs, un bloc en disant
que je ne sais plus qui était le vol de
mort de la finance. Ça existe ces
caractères existent. Vous savez, tous
les caractères de l'humanité se
retrouvent en banque comme ils se
retrouvent partout ailleurs.
Parce que ce qui m'a frappé et on est
sur un autre terrain mais on est en
plein dedans. Donc qu'est-ce que nous
venons de découvrir ? C'est l'ampleur du
problème de la pédophilie.
D'accord. C'est quand même épouvantable.
Mais ce n'est que 6 % dans les églises.
Ça veut dire que 94 % se sont passés
ailleurs dans les écoles. Et quel est le
premier
endroit
le plus important de la pédophilie ?
C'est la famille.
D'accord. Donc nous nous rendons compte
que tout le problème de la relation
entre les hommes et les femmes, du
dialogue
pour le moment est extraordinairement
difficile parce qu'il est devenu très
antagoniste.
Je voyais encore un article, je ne sais
pas quoi. Ça c'est la faute du
patriarcat. D'accord ? Quand une femme a
quelque chose qui va pas très bien,
c'est la faute du patriarcat. Les hommes
vont dire la même chose. Ça c'est la
cause des femmes et cetera. On a on doit
essayer de retrouver un moyen de se
parler de manière authentique
à l'intérieur. Je parle pas de la
famille ici, je parle à l'intérieur des
entreprises, à l'intérieur des
communautés, à l'intérieur de tout ce
que nous faisons.
C'est un grand chantier.
Commentaire internet qui n'est pas un
commentaire qui est une question parce
qu'une femme doit avoir une vie de
famille. Du coup, elles vont pas dans le
dans dans ce domaine. C'est pas un peu
machisme que de dire ça ?
Pas du tout, pas du tout. Je n'ai pas
dit que les femmes J'ai dit que les
certaines femmes choisissaient
une vie de famille qui n'était pas
compatible avec certains métiers de la
finance et que donc il y avait moins de
femmes dans ce secteur là. C'est pas une
analyse de machisme. Par contre,
si la question que vous posez est de
savoir si oui ou non on intègre la
maternité ou des éléments comme ceux-là,
je peux vous dire aujourd'hui que quand
je vois j'ai des enfants qui sont su
Morgan quand je vois la manière dont
quand il y a un un problème subitement
un enfant est malade ou il y a quelque
chose, il y a une crèche pas loin qui
est organisée par la banque pour que la
personne puisse venir au bureau et venir
voir son enfant à midi et cetera. Il y a
un chemin considérable qui est fait et
qui doit encore être fait. On n'est pas
loin par rapport à là où on devrait
être. Mais je crois que nous sommes
arrivés quand même à un niveau dans
lequel par rapport à ce que moi j'ai
connu quand je suis devenu père de
famille, il y a quand même euh une un
élément important. La deuxième élément
qui est probablement le plus délicat et
le plus difficile c'est la
réintégration.
Et là il y a du chemin à faire.
C'est-à-dire qu'il faut absolument que
les 6 mois maison où une femme reste à
la maison parce qu'elle a décidé de
s'occuper de ses enfants et qu'elle
prend son congé de maternité ne doit
rien les coucher, ne lui tout le lui
coûter ni au point de vue carrière ni au
point de vue financier. Et elle doit
pouvoir savoir quand elle quitte
que le système va la réintégrer parce
que sinon vous allez avoir un problème
d'une toute autre nature.
Question internet. Quelles sont les
banques les plus solides ou les moins
solides ?
Il y a une catégorie de banques qui dans
le cadre de la réglementation financière
ont été appelés les CFI en anglais
systematically important financial
institution. Donc des entreprises, des
banques qui sont considérées comme étant
tel que on peut pas se permettre de les
laisser tomber. D'accord ? La liste est
publiée donc on les connaît.
Ces banques ont des obligations de fonds
propres supérieures aux autres parce que
comme elles représentent un risque, il
faut qu'elle soit particulièrement bien
soutenue parce qu'on pourra pas les
sauver.
Big to fail, c'est ça
? Tout big to fail, vous avez
parfaitement compris. to jail ou tout
big to manage.
Et donc par rapport à ces banques là, ce
que ce dont vous vous rendez compte,
c'est que elles ont effectivement
derrière elles
une forme de contrôle, de garantie, de
soutien qui fait qu'elles ont quelque
chose de plus qu'une banque qui ne fait
pas partie de cette catégorie là, à la
fois dans les obligations et dans la
robustesse. Donc si vous allez dans
cette catégorie là, vous risquez pas de
vous tromper.
Question internet. George a-t-il déjà
rencontré Macron ? Oui. Alors,
Emmanuel Macron est venu à Je suis
professeur Colombia
et je fais partie de l'Institut européen
de Columbia University.
Et donc Emmanuel Macron, vous vous en
souviendrez, en campagne
est venu faire un petit rou de show aux
États-Unis et à New York en Belgique
et on l'a invité à Colombia. Institut
européen
a s'adresser aux étudiants.
C'est le rocha qu'il a payé quand il
était ministre des finances ou il était
plus ministre des finances ? Je
sais plus. Je sais plus. Là c'était pour
savoir si c'était un road show organisé
sur nos deniers ou cit cétait sur
non il était en campagne. il était en
campagne donc il était déconnecté
et donc il est venu et nous avons comme
nous le faisons dans les bonnes
universités nous avons organisé un
déjeuner en son honneur avec un certain
nombre de professeurs intéressés par
l'Europe et cetera et j'en étais
et j'ai vu Emmanuel Macron
pour qui j'avais une sympathie naturelle
non pas parce que je le connaissais mais
parce que il fait partie de la catégorie
des gens que j'ai rencontré dans les
banques d'affaires
particulièrement en France. Il y a un
type du banquier d'affaires français
modèle lycée rectifié 36 la chemise
blanche le pantalon noir et cetera.
Enfin tout ça vous les reconnaissez ils
ont façon de parler sont très
intéressants. Bien bref
ça parce que c'est c'est très
intéressant c'est du sarcasme.
Non c'est pas du sarcasme c'est
peut-être de l'humour. Je spect du se
bien. [soupir][souffle coupé]
Donc je reste sur ce la situation et
donc il nous explique une série de
choses
et je vous avoue que j'ai trouvé et je
crois que beaucoup de Français l'ont
fait et beaucoup d'autres. J'ai trouvé
que son articulation était intéressante
jusqu'au jour c'est j'ai moi posé une
question.
Ma question c'est sur le Breaksheit.
La question c'était
et je pense que monsieur Macron ne doit
pas avoir connu des relations
extrêmement
amical
avec la cité de Londres
et avec le Brexit.
Bref,
sans avoir t sur le fond, j'ai senti
quand même que c'était un sujet un peu
délicat mais je l'ai trouvé très bon.
Et puis il est allé parler aux étudiants
et j'ai dû en poser des questions et il
a été très bon.
Et mes collègues m'ont dit "Alors,
qu'est-ce que tu as pensé de Macron ?"
J'ai répondu, ils sera un très bon
président dans 4 ans, dans 5 ans.
Enrièrement, nous avons dit,
il est arrivé pour moi, il est arrivé
comme président trop tôt à cause des
circonstances qui se sont passées dans
les circonstances électorales. Il
n'aurait pas dû être le meilleur
candidat possible quand on avait des
jupés, des fillons et des choses comme
ça. C'est un problème de génération. Et
5 ans plus tard, il aurait probablement
été très bon. Il a peut-être été
ministre des finances, il aurait vécu
des expériences gouvernementales. Il
s'est trouvé subitement mis.
au sommet de l'État. Et là, je suis
obligé de dire le rôle, c'est pas du
tout le même rôle qu'un ministre ou
d'avoir été à l'Élysée dans un cabinet
ou d'avoir été un banquier d'affaires.
Mais
c'est mon expérience de rencontre avec
Emmanuel Macron. Je le connaissais
d'avant parce que je l'avais rencontré
chez Rotchild M de manière assez
passagère.
Est-ce que vous voyez des choses
que vous souhaiteriez aborder avec nous
? Est-ce que vous avez un sujet, une
question, un questionnement ?
Je crois
que ce qui se passe dans la finance
n'est possible que parce que la
communication est muselée.
Et ce n'est pas seulement dans le cas de
la finance que parce que l'éducation est
inexistante.
Donc on peut faire avaler à peu près
n'importe quoi à n'importe qui.
Tant que nous n'aurons pas déchiré la
voile du temple et qu'on a'ura pas vu
clairement les forces en puissance, le
contrôle démocratique ne pourra pas se
réaliser et les inégalités continueront.
Question internet, le frexit, c'est une
solution ou un problème ?
Le Brexit, après ce que vous avez vu sur
le Brexit, ce qui ça coûte aux anglais.
Bonne chance, hein.
Euh, est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ? Pardon ?
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Je suis un tout petit peu embarrassé, je
vous le dis tout de suite, parce que il
faut que vous compreniez que je suis
beaucoup parce que dans ce domaine c'est
important, y compris pour mon
enseignement de la
de la littérature anglo-saxone. Je vais
parler de deux livres
qui m'ont impressionné en France
et celui que j'ai trouvé moi le plus
intéressant, mais c'est peut-être pas ce
qui intéresse plus le public, c'est le
journal
de Michel Barnier.
La grande force c'est que c'est un
journal et on voit au fur et à mesure
évoluer et sa pensée et le comportement
des anglais.
Vous fermez le bouquin et vous dites les
anglais sont complètement à côté de la
plaque. J'ai travaillé avec en
collaboration sur le Brexit avec les
anglais et avec l'équipe et avec Michel
Barnier.
Et bien ça fait du bien de lire un livre
comme ça en se disant "Nous avons des
hommes d'état et je ne prends pas
position sur une sur une situation
électorale. Michel Barnier est plus
qu'un grand comis de l'État. C'est un
grand chef, un grand homme d'État. Il a
une ouverture. Vous savez ce qu'il a
fait de plus extraordinaire ? Toutes les
semaines, lui et son équipe, allaient
dans une capital différente pour
rencontrer. Il ne rencontrait pas
seulement les gouvernements, il
rencontrait les syndicats, il
rencontrait la société civile et cetera.
Et c'est comme ça que le le Brexit a été
aussi réussi et que la collision
cohésion européenne a pu être
constituée. Je peux vous dire que quand
j'ai écrit mon premier papier sur le
Brexit, j'ai dit "Les anglais n'en
feront qu'une bouchée parce que l'Europe
ne parviendra jamais à se mettre
d'accord.
Michel Barnier avec Junker, avec Orsula
Vline et avec les autres ont réussi un
paris auquel au départ je ne croyais
pas. Donc c'est tout à fait remarquable.
Ça c'est un premier livre. Il y a un
deuxième livre dont j'oublie le nom
malheureusement qui est le dernier
concours et je suis en plein dedans.
L'histoire des avions et cetera. Vous
voyez de quoi je parle ? On va demander
à la communauté de nous retrouver ça
tout de suite.
Oui. Euh je le trouve intéressant parce
qu'il est
il crée des réflexions sur une espèce de
de
personnalité qui se fait une espèce de
dédoublement de personnalité à travers
le le le comment dirais-je le l'équipage
de l'avion. Il y a deux livres en
anglais. Ah oui troisème en économie. Le
dernier livre d'Arthus sur la fin du
capitalisme mérite d'être lu. Il y a
beaucoup de similarité entre ce qu'il
écrit et ce que j'écris.
Dans les livres anglo-saxons, il y a
deux grands livres pour moi. Le premier,
c'est écrit par quelqu'un que je connais
qui s'appelle Ragouram. Je connais tous
les deux. Ragouram Rajan. Ragouram était
le chief économiste de du fond
monétaire. Il est indien. Il a il est
devenu professeur à Chicago. Il a quitté
Chicago pour devenir le conseiller du
premier ministre indien. Et puis il est
devenu gouverneur de la banque centrale
indienne. Et quand le gouvernement
indien a voulu faire faire à la banque
centrale quelque chose qui n'était pas
correct, il est reparti et il est
rentré. Il a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle State and Markets have abandon
the community. C'est-à-dire que le
secteur public et les marchés ont
abandonné les communautés et l'aspect
humain. Remarquable [grognement] et
c'est une démonstration historique et
internationale. Donc ça ne date pas
d'hier.
Vous cherchez c'est l'anomalie de Hervé
le Tellerier.
Voilà.
Et le tr le dernier c'est une collègue
d'origine allemande. Elle s'appelle
Catarina Pistor
et c'est très intéressant et j'en parle
dans mon livre.
C'est quoi le nom de votre livre déjà ?
Le livre c'est
Wall Street à l'assaut de la démocratie.
Comment les marchés financiers
exacerbent les inégalités chez Audit
Jacob ?
Le troisème est écrit par une collègue
qui est une grande juriste.
Ça s'appelle le code du capital. The
code of capital. Ça pas encore été
traduit en français. Elle s'appelle
Catarina Pistor.
Comment la loi favorise toujours
les riches ?
Restera colombien.
D'accord. Il y a une caractéristique
dans ces deux livres.
C'est écrit par des étrangers qui sont
devenus américains.
Les Américains n'écriraient pas ces
livres là. C'est pour ça qu'il faut
faire de l'international.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose qui va rester
impérissable sur les réseaux.
Je voudrais que ce soit compris dans un
sens extraordinairement positif
parce que ça peut être mal compris.
Vous arrivez avec toute une série
d'opinions.
Je vous demande de faire l'effort de
vous former, de vous informer avant
d'aller trop vite aux conclusions parce
que les slogans, c'est facile. Et par
exemple, si vous avez un problème avec
une situation, renseignez-vous,
formez-vous. Vous ne pouvez pas vous
permettre d'entrer dans le monde dans
lequel, complexe dans lequel nous sommes
sans être formé par rapport aux
problématiques qui vous intéressent. Et
donc n'oubliez pas qu'en dehors de
l'éducation que vous recevez de vos
parents des études, c'est vous qui devez
vous former pour vous-même. Et donc ne
vous laissez pas prendre au miroir aux
alhouettes des slogans. Par contre,
continuez le combat.
George Jugeu, merci.
[musique]